hi everyone welcome to day 4 of digital
marketing week by simply learn on day
three we looked at Social Media
Marketing today we are going to learn
two important skills in digital
marketing that is email and content
marketing email is one of the oldest
forms of digital communication and every
professional uses it email marketing is
still ranked as the most effective
marketing channel surpassing social
media SEO and affiliate marketing it is
easy effective and inexpensive it also
lets you build brand awareness and
appeal and is perfect for personalized
targeted messaging content marketing on
the other hand helps answer your
audience questions and allows you to
build trust develop relationships
improve conversations educate your
audience and generate leads so in
today's live session we will cover what
is email marketing benefits of email
marketing and understand how to automate
emails and learn the types of email
marketing Champions then we will
understand what is content marketing
look at the different content marketing
strategies and learn the important
content marketing interview questions
and answers so let's begin with what is
email marketing welcome everyone this is
Rob Sanders with simply learn and
welcome today we're going to talk about
email marketing tutorial so buckle up
and let's get started with email
marketing tutorial and so let's start
out asking the question why email
marketing so Linda is the owner of an
e-commerce company and basically she
isn't able to take her leads the lead
she's collecting per day per month and
convert them into customers okay so
customers sign up but they don't buy her
product so she's left scratching her
head wondering what to do so how's she
going to solve the problem of converting
the lead she gets into paying customers
well look no further than email market
so you can boost your sales funnel what
the hell help of email marketing so
email marketing leads to email campaigns
that lead to website visits that can
lead to product purchasing email
markings also in a it's a very good way
to generate a high return on investment
so Linda thinks this is too good to be
true your telling me is a very efficient
way to generate a return on my
investment how expensive is email
marketing well email marketing is
neither expensive or time consuming
that's the beauty of email marketing and
so Linda is now very interested we've
piqued her interest she wants us to
explain email marketing to her in detail
and that's exactly what we're going to
do buckle up and let's get started and
talk about what is email marketing so as
I mentioned to Linda it's an efficient
way to convert leads into sales why
because we can send personalized emails
to a specific audience a targeted
audience if somebody's interested in our
product we can reach out to them via
email it can also be used to remarket
pre-qualified leads so anybody who's
pre-qualified we can go ahead and
communicate with them as well so email
marketing is a very effective at
different stages in the funnel okay so
when I say funnel customer life cycle so
we have awareness consideration purchase
retention and advocacy okay so let's
talk about each one of these parts of
the final or customer life cycle if you
will so let's start with awareness at
the very top so email marketing allows
customers to recognize their problems
after which you can educate them on how
your brand can solve them okay just like
any other marketing channel somebody's
looking for something a need of
something we can come to the rescue in
this case we're going to come to the
rescue with email and we can go ahead
and educate them on on what their need
is and how we can collaborate with them
help them educate them solve their
problems with our product okay so that's
what email is going to do we're going to
communicate with them via email and
we're going to bring awareness to the
problem by solving the problem that's
what email is good for okay good for
generating awareness for our brand for
example we can share a newsletter with
our customers so we're running a
Cosmetics company we can basically
educate them on the five important skin
care products that everyone should have
okay so we can get them to click on the
call to action to learn more so if
somebody's having some skin care issues
or not sure what products to buy you
know an email can cover that okay the
next step in the customer life cycle is
consideration so customers focused on
searching for Relevant products and
compares the products with similar ones
okay so they're definitely looking
they're a little further in the process
they're educated they know what they're
looking for so we can really hit them
with the right email we can send a
relevant email to promote our product
okay discover that perfect moisturizer
for your skin that perfect skin
moisturizer Smooths hydrates and
contains SPF 20. so we got the perfect
product for that person who's further
along the funnel and really is ready to
purchase that product so we can hit that
person up with the perfect messaging
let's talk about purchase the next step
in the life cycle well purchase well
with purchase we can send an email that
encourages that customer purchase our
product by offering them something okay
by giving an offer for example we can
give a discount discounts always tend to
work so that moisturizer that that
particular customer was considering
buying well they can can move from
consideration to purchasing because
we're going to offer them a discount
they can't refuse okay so you know it
could beat for a specific date okay it
could be you know something that's going
to get them excited to buy the product
20 off a moisturizer is pretty good deal
and especially if that percentage off is
better than the other products they were
considering buying so getting somebody
that extra incentive to purchase the
product goes a long way via email okay
we want to take that next step in the
life cycle and nurture our relationship
with customers to ensure they're loyal
okay they've already purchased how do we
get them purchased again that's
retention we want to retain our
customers we want to get them back to
buy the same product or similar products
or completely different products in
their inventory so what do we do we're
going to send an email we're going to
see an email to active customers okay
we're gonna give them an offer just for
them exclusively just for them in this
example we're going to give them a combo
pack a facial kit at just 39 and get a
sunscreen worth ten dollars for free so
you can come up with all sorts of
different combinations on offers he is
the offers exclusively just for those
who you want to Target and retain as
customers because if you just get
somebody to purchase once it's not gonna
work those people have already taken the
that step in the relationship where they
trust your product they purchase your
product now you want to go ahead and
treat that customer special by giving
them an exclusive offer then what we
want to do is advocacy last step in that
customer lifestyle we want to convert
that active customer into brand
Advocates okay we want that customer to
talk about our brand for us we want them
to promote it and talk about it with
your friends so for example we want to
send an email to those customers to
promote our products okay so for example
we could say hey the sales of our
products for this particular day or for
this month is going to go to our
favorite non-profit could be educating
poor children or cleaning up plastic in
the ocean or saving animals we want to
be able to get them to speak on our
behalf and say look guys this is a
really good company you know they're
offering me products exclusively they've
offered me discounts in the past they
have good products they have a lot of
different products and on top of all
that they help they help the environment
they help the needy okay they care and
so we can go ahead and provide a call to
action for these customers that are
loyal to our brand and have them share
the email with their friends to spread
the word on you know what we're trying
to accomplish for our non-profit or if
anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount for every
friend that they get to buy a product
okay it doesn't have to necessarily be
be you know just sharing with Friends it
can be that extra incentive of giving
them a discount if they do share with
friends and their friends buy okay so
this is the customer life cycle and
examples of different emails that you
can use at every step along the way in
the life cycle so let's talk about email
marketing set up so email marketing set
up we have a series of steps that we
need to go through in order to get our
email set up to go ahead and send out to
our target audience and that first step
is we want to identify that target
audience and create segments so if
you've taken some of my and listened to
some of my webinars in the past about
Google analytics about Google ads we
talk about segmenting so it's about
targeting a specific audience that's
what segmenting is taking a piece of the
whole so we don't want to email all
users on our list all customers maybe we
want to Target a specific segment Okay
so so we want to be able to identify
that segment who is that segment is it
somebody who or a group of people or you
know a partial list of our customers who
purchase a specific product I would say
so versus say our entire list of
customers because our entire list of
customers can purchase a number of
different products and so by targeting a
specific segment of our audience or our
customer base we can hone in on the
message so if they all have something in
common like they all bought that
moisturizer then we can go ahead and be
specific with our messaging then we want
to create campaigns and set an
appropriate call to action okay so what
is it that we want to say to these these
people this segment of users then once
you create that campaign and and set up
the messaging and call to action we want
to test the email before we actually
click Send this is a very important step
test that email before we send and then
when we send the campaigns immediately
or we can schedule a time so my advice
here is always schedule a time you want
to be able to figure out the best time
to send that email and then once the
email's sent whenever that is you want
to be able to analyze performance and
there are some key metrics that you want
to hone in on when we talk about email
marketing and some of those are open
rates click-through rates okay response
rate okay so we want to be able to hone
in on certain key metrics when it comes
to emails so here's what we need to do
create our list add contacts to our list
create our campaign okay we want to
select the list choose a format modify
the template and then send the email
campaign so these are some basic
checklists that you want to do so let me
give you an example and go to MailChimp
so if I'm in MailChimp basically I'm
going to create a campaign okay so it's
an email that I'm going to to work with
and you can see with MailChimp I have
some some examples Here regular
automated plain text or a B test I want
to do a regular email hey I'm just going
to call it test and I'm going to click
begin okay so we want to add our
recipients who are we going to add so
we're going to choose our audience okay
so we're just going to choose a sample
test for now okay we can personalize the
to field if we want okay so what do we
want to do we want to call people by
their first name their last name their
first and last name where we can
customize it just go with first name to
keep it a little bit personal okay then
we have the subject line here so it's
all about messaging right so whoever
we're targeting we want to be able to
add a message so we're just going to say
and and subject line is very key here so
you want to have a subject line that's
really going to resonate with your
audience so whoever that segment
audience is we want to make sure that
the subject line is going to resonate
with with them so that they can open up
that email okay so uh we'll just say
having a good day we can make it better
just as an example something that's
going to be attention grabbing if you
will okay you can always tweak the
subject line in fact my advice is always
do a b testing on the subject line so
you can do two different subject lines
with one email to figure out which one
has better open rates and then with
MailChimp we can go ahead and design the
content of our email so we're going to
click design email okay we can select a
template we have some save templates
already okay or we can go with a theme
so MailChimp has a lot of good offers
now there's a lot of different email
platforms out there I particularly like
MailChimp because of this very feature
they have a lot of good themes here a
lot of different layouts that you can
use okay so you know we're going to
Showcase that product okay and that's
the template we're going to use here so
here we go we're going to showcase our
product we're going to add that photo of
our product here and we're gonna go
ahead and put some nice messaging in
here with some nice call to action we
can put our logo up here for Branding
again we can edit the content here so
based on that segmented list in this
example for Linda's company maybe she
wants to Target those folks who bought
her moisturizer before her face
moisturizer and she wants to retarget
them she wants to go ahead and say hey
you guys have bought my product before
check out this new face moisturizer that
we have to offer so whatever the case is
you want to be able to plan that out
ahead of time you want to be able to
plan out who your audience is you want
to plan out your messaging and you want
to go ahead and set up the messaging
based on that audience so once you have
the messaging in place voila you're more
or less ready to go okay so once you get
the content all set up
you can schedule that campaign okay and
you can also add a social post to your
campaign so we can share that
information on social so email
integrates nicely with social media so
again that's that's pretty much what you
need to do here you need to really think
about who it is you want to Target
choose those recipients okay customize
it and make it personal create a good
subject line in fact create two subject
lines and then align that content with
that audience okay that's that's really
the checklist here so again we look at
this checklist creating our list who do
we want to send the email to so we added
our contacts to the list we set up the
campaign we selected the list we chose
the format we modified it with a good
subject line with some good messaging
and then we're going to schedule that
email campaign so that's the checklist
to go off of okay so remember identify
AI target audience and create segments
then you create that campaign and in our
case we did set an appropriate call to
action you know get shopping basically
we want people to shop our new
moisturizer key thing here is before we
send it out we want to test that email
once everything looks good we're going
to I would if I schedule it but you can
always send the email when you're ready
I would schedule it at the appropriate
time of day okay so in this case you
don't want to send an email out on a
Friday afternoon okay when people are
getting ready for the weekend you
certainly don't want to send an email
out over the weekend because you're not
going to have many people look and open
it and you probably don't want to send
the email out on a Monday morning when
most people are getting into the office
from a long weekend and catching up on
emails so from my experience you know
Tuesday Wednesday depending on your time
zone I would always say you know late
morning early afternoon tends to be a
good time but that's why we have
performance that's why we can analyze
performance we want to be able to see
what the open rates are and the
click-through rates are so that we can
make adjustments for future emails so
let's talk about some of those metrics
so when you do send that email you know
we're going to look at that open so open
rate is the percentage of the total
number of recipients who open an email
so okay so if we basically you know set
it to x amount of people minus those
emails that have bounced so let's just
say you know we sent it to
102 people okay for simplicity's sake
two of those emails bounced okay so that
means that we've had a hundred net 100
emails that receive the email and let's
just say 75 open the email okay we wrote
such a good subject line that they
opened it okay that's 75 percent that's
a 75 open rate that's how you measure
open rate click-through rate okay so if
they open it we hope that they click on
something and so for all of those emails
that were delivered okay in this case a
hundred how many actually did click on
our call to action so let's just say 75
opened it out of the hundred that's a 75
open rate but of the 100 that actually
were delivered let's just say we had 25
that actually clicked on the call to
action and so that's 25 okay and so you
want to be able to measure not only who
opens it but who clicks on the call to
action so that's click-through rate for
email marketing and then response rate
so it's the percentage of the total
recipients who clicked on a link of your
email campaign and actually completed
the action so in our example we're
trying to get people to click on the
shopping call to action and get them to
purchase so we set 100 emails and of the
25 who actually clicked we had 10 who
actually took action and purchase so 10
divided by 100 is 10 so you have open
rate click the rate and response rate
those are some key metrics for email
marketing okay the first step is you got
to get people to open it that's where
the subject line is so important click
their way that's where the messaging and
call to action is so important we want
to get people to click on that call to
action and then the response rate we
want them to buy so those are our three
key metrics related to email marketing
so let's take a look at an example if we
go back to our email marketing platform
MailChimp in this example we're going to
take a look at some reports so most
email marketing platforms have reporting
functionality built in and so in this
case what we want to do is we want to be
able to take a look at the open Rate
click-through rates of the emails that
have been sent out previously so here we
could see our April email coupon versus
tools promo Okay so we've had basically
you know opens and click X so 14 open
rate one point four percent
click-through rate so the March email
that went out did a little bit better 19
open two and a half percent on the
click-through rate so here we could see
how many people actually were sent how
many opened it and how many clicks so
this is a MailChimp makes it very easily
for us to measure you know open and
click rates and then we can measure by
Revenue as well based on the campaign so
that's measuring the response rate so
it's all built in so most email
marketing platforms have open right and
clicked right already built into the
functionality so you can measure those
two metrics against any email so let's
talk about the benefits of email
marketing so what are some of the
benefits well we've already mentioned to
Linda that it's cost effective it's time
saving real-time marketing less
intrusive builds credibility increases
visibility and brand awareness and it's
an easy way to track Roi these are all
the benefits for email marketing we're
going to go talk about some of these now
so may basically when we talk about cost
effective you know some email marketing
platforms charge based on the number of
users who you send the email to time
saving well you saw how quick it took me
to set up that email campaign the key is
figuring out who you want to send it to
then we talk about real-time marketing
you know we're sending this email out
basically in real time trying to meet
our customers needs at the right time
it's less intrusive because we can
customize the emails okay we can as you
saw I can put first name in there to
make it more personal so when
something's more personal it's less
intrusive especially if it's a segment
that already knows your brand okay
builds credibility hey we gain
credibility when we offer exclusive
offers to repeat customers or you know
try and build advocacy by working with
non-profits okay and increases
visibility and brand awareness why
because you know we could send our email
out to a large group of people and
that's a good way to generate brand
awareness and as you saw we can easily
measure you know not only open rates
click rates but Roi so how many people
from that email went on and purchased so
we can measure that it's very easy to
measure email so let's move into a b
testing so a b testing is key to email
marketing okay so in email marketing
gaining High open rates and
click-through rates will result in more
website visitors and sales okay in
theory that's what's supposed to happen
we get more opens we get more people to
click we get more people to click we're
going to get more people to purchase
okay but it's not as easy as it sounds
so how do we make that possible well
we're going to do that via a b testing
I've already mentioned it when I set up
my example campaign in MailChimp I
stressed and stressed and stressed that
we need to have two subject lines go out
per email okay so before I stress that
again let me just reiterate what a b
testing is and a b testing is a method
to analyze which of the two email
campaign strategies most effective in
terms of high open rates and click rates
okay so in this case an A B test you can
send out two emails you can send out two
subject lines you can send out to call
to actions you're just really what
you're doing is you're testing one
against the other that's what a b
testing is and so in my example I talked
about that subject line so for better
results a b testing can be done with the
subject line can also be done with the
email content so the subject line
impacts the open rate okay so I wrote a
subject line I don't even know how that
subject line is going to perform but if
I write a second subject line then I'll
be able to basically give myself a
better chance of getting a better open
right because I'm offering up two
different subject lines like wise for
email content so the subject line and
email content are the most important
elements so we want to be able to test
them if they're interesting intriguing
attention grabbing then it's gonna in
the case of subject lines a result in
open rates if the content itself is
interesting engaging a good offer good
call to action then the click rates are
going to be increased so we want to be
able to serve up variations for our
audience so we want to consider an
example of an A B test where Linda has
set up two variations of the email
campaign as an example so she's gonna
send two different subject lines to test
which one generates more open rates
because that's what subject line a b
testing is going to do one of them is
going to have a higher open rate okay so
in our example here Linda sends version
a of the email to fifty percent of the
recipients with the subject line three
important strategies to increase your
open rate well version B which is sent
to the other 50 percent has the subject
line three important strategies to
increase your open rate so the only
difference here is three and three the
number three spelled out well because
she sent out two different subject lines
she's going to now be able to measure
the success of that A B test okay and it
just so happens version a has a higher
open rate number is always tend to work
in subject Lines by the way so Linda
sends version a of the email to fifty
percent of the recipients okay eighty
dollars today but ninety dollars
tomorrow and version B to the remaining
fifty percent eighty dollars today
ninety dollars tomorrow and the only
really succinct difference here is using
the word but versus a comma and she sent
that email out and that email went out
and the data is coming in and she's
gonna measure the success of that A B
test well version B has the high fire
open right you know we want to be short
succinct and stay away from those
conjugations like butt okay it tends to
have a negative connotation so the
shorter more direct email or subject
line 80 today 90 tomorrow not so passive
more direct and that tend to have the
higher open rate so you always want to
test those subject lines to generate
High open rates another example here
version a again gets 50 percent with the
subject line uh oh your prescription is
expiring version B your prescription is
expiring you folks listen to this
webinar right now I wonder which one you
think will perform go ahead and put your
comments right below this video I'm
curious what version of the subject line
you would open so let's go ahead and
measure the success of the A B test okay
so she sent the email out two different
subject lines fifty percent got one
subject line the other fifty percent got
the others subject line and it just so
happens version a uh-oh your
prescription is expiring there's a
little bit of a you know personalization
to that you know for me your
prescription is expiring seems to be a
little bit more you know command-ish hey
your prescriptions expiring so we expect
you to purchase where you have the
little uh-oh in front it's like hey you
know I think your prescription is
expiring maybe you should think about
renewing it okay I think that's how
that's interpreted at least that's how I
interpret it so I would probably go
ahead and click on that email with that
subject line so you could see subtle
differences in the subject lines make a
big difference in open rights so in
order to keep improving those open rates
you need to continue and not continue
you should always do subject line
testing always because one subject line
is always going to have a better open
rate than the other so all always do a b
testing when it comes to subject lines
and email content for that matter okay
so we're always going to do continuous a
b testing so with continuous a b testing
we can test very various elements of the
email so you can always test the
sender's name the subject line the copy
the call to action the design the
imagery there's a lot of different
elements you can test with emails for
example sender's name okay so you want
to personalize it as much as you can
okay you don't want to do a no reply you
want it to come from a human being in
this case Sam okay at least that's what
I think let's see what the test States
no surprise version a has the higher
open rate if you customize these things
and personalize them then it goes a long
way sending an email from a no reply is
not a good best practice let's talk
about the subject line again uh so we
got webinar increase your email open
rights webinar increase your email open
rates so the webinar is dynamic on
version a okay so we're sending that out
and because it's Dynamic that's going to
you know beat out the static webinar
increase your email open rates a lot
more elements we can test here so for
example the email copy to learn some
easy ways to increase your email
operates join us on May 10 2019 7 PM for
an interactive discussion with our
experts well version B is more
personalized it's the same message but
we're actually addressing someone
specific in this case Rachel so we can
measure the success of the A B test but
it's no surprise that anything that's
customized that comes from somebody a
name you know with a dynamic email
subject line is going to perform better
it's going to increase open rates and
it's it's going to increase click rates
so we can also test that call to action
the difference here is coloring save my
seat yellow versus save my seat blue
again go ahead and play along here if
you're watching this go ahead and add a
comment and just see if you're right you
think it's blue or you think it's yellow
on the call to action color does go a
long way in email marketing so let's
measure the success so this A B test and
it just so happens yellow is going to
perform better why does yellow perform
better than blue well what's more
positive plus it it kind of resonates a
little bit stronger and easier okay it
stands out a little bit better it's not
as pastely and dull as this shade of
blue we're using so you can see here
we're testing every bit of the elements
of the email anything from the from to
the subject line to the message to the
call to action and so at the end of the
day you know you want to be able to send
out the best email that's going to give
you the best results so we're going to
send that out the entirety of the email
and we could see version a looks a lot
better and why does version a look a lot
better in this example because look at
the font size is a little bit bigger
version B font size smaller harder to
read that's another thing you can test
larger fonts tend to do a little bit
better now you don't want to go
overboard and have them you know 48
points or 50 points or plus you know 14
versus 12 goes a long way we can
continue testing we can test imagery you
can see here we have a hand aligned with
the call to action they just look
different that's all version a has one
type of hand version B has the other
type of hand aligned with the call to
action let's go ahead and send out that
test and see what works well version B
works why the hand stands out a little
bit more clear it doesn't blend in with
the call to action so you can see we're
testing different elements here and
we're always improving and adding to
what's working so we started out with a
no reply versus somebody's name then we
moved to a subject line then we moved to
personalization then we move to you know
call to action then we move to an
increased font meaning the design and
then we're adding imagery so we're
constantly improving the email with each
test eventually you're going to get to a
point where you know the email is going
to be good and you're going to just
continue to test different options on it
to continue to increase open rates click
rates and response rates final output
looks like this again that personalized
email response from Sam versus no reply
you know we got a nice Dynamic subject
line got a personalized email to Rachel
with larger fonts okay we got a nice
call to action that stands out with a
nice image to accompany that so we've
tested all these different elements this
is the best combination based on
everything we tested so when we get that
email to go this is what it's going to
look like in the future but guess what
we're not going to stop testing so we
can continue to test those subject lines
continue to test the messaging and
continue to test the email design
continue to test different call to
actions continue to test different
images you're never going to stop
testing with email marketing okay so
let's switch over to how to optimize the
subject line subject line is such a key
component to email marketing so as we
showed you in the last segment we tested
a subject line and we used a number the
number three versus three spelled out
just so happens that numbers tend to do
a little bit better they're shorter
easier to read and they resonate better
so including number in your subject line
you can include an emoji in your subject
line emails come along Long Way emojis
aren't just social media based you can
use emojis in subject lines I'd highly
recommend it you know I just sat on an
email last month with the subject line
about you know spring showers bring May
flowers and guess what emoji I had in
that subject line a flower okay may
sound cheesy but it goes a long way so
according to Experian subject lines with
emojis can increase open rates by 45
people resonate with Emojis especially
if they're positive emojis okay so we
want to personalize those subject lines
for better open rate okay when I say
personalize don't be so stale remember
that subject line we tested uh oh just
putting uh-oh in there made it sound
like we actually cared it was a little
bit personal it wasn't so personal we
weren't dressed in a specific person but
one little word goes a long way in a
subject line because when people get
emails and they read emails and a lot of
people people are inundated with emails
the subject line is what they're reading
first and just by personalizing it
adding a number add an emoji I'm just
making it positive and easier to read
They're likely to open on email it's a
personalized email messages can improve
click-through rate and open rates as
well so you want to personalize your
email as much as you can whether that be
from the from field to putting that
person's name in the salutation it's a
personalized subject lines have been
found to increase open rates by up to 50
percent so don't come across as spammy
come across as you know who your
audience is and you're talking to them
and then you want to prefer title case
subject lines so title face subject
lines for example when I say title case
Game of Thrones is my favorite show
every initial letter in that title is
capitalized okay you can go with the
sentence case Game of Thrones is my
favorite show it doesn't stand out as
much core if you go in lower case it
definitely doesn't stand out it looks
illiterate and somebody's probably not
going to open it so you always go with
that title case the every initial letter
gets capitalized so how to optimize that
subject line well watch the length of
your subject line you want to be
conscious of character counts so 17 to
24 characters you want to keep it short
succinct and to the point but
personalized with an emoji with initial
caps on each word to make it stand out
but you have to do that within 70 10 17
and 24 characters so according to
campaign monitor the ideal length of a
subject line is up to 24 characters and
they're more likely to boost those email
rates okay so keep it short make it
impactful make it personalized like I
mentioned before if it gets too long
then it may get cut off and it may not
have the same impact as something
shorter so that's why we always
recommend keeping it up to about 24
characters okay if you go over by a
couple characters not the end of the
world but try and stay within that range
develop a sense of urgency okay so when
we say sense of urgency we mean sense of
urgency meaning if that coupon is going
to expire you know you want to let
people know it's going to expire that
day or the next day or within a few days
okay so you can use things like hurry up
or limit offer or Limited stock or offer
expires on okay so add a bit of sense of
urgency I mean Sky's not falling here
but if that coupon's expiring at the end
of the week you probably want to mention
something to the effect of hey offers
expiring or hurry up so let's talk about
optimizing your email content so we
focused a lot on subject lines let's
talk about the email content itself so
some ways to optimize email content are
we want to send the content that is
relevant to customer expectation so
content needs to match that expectation
want to use bullet points to make the
content readable we want to follow
logical structure we want to use
compelling imagery and for design emails
with responsive designs and what we mean
by responsive design is hey most people
are going to be checking that email on
their mobile phone okay so make sure
when you design the email it's also
going to be good not just on desktop but
on tablet and mobile as well and then of
course goes without saying but avoid
grammatical mistakes go ahead and spell
check it and that's why we put an
emphasis on testing your email before
you actually send it and when you
actually send an email test email don't
send it to yourself send it to
colleagues you know send it to another
group a fresh set of eyes a fresh set of
eyes that is going to be able to pick
out that misspelled word that you
overlooked so I can't stress us the
sending of the test email because it's
going to be able to you know in a way
ensure that you're doing everything on
this list in addition to grammatical
mistakes you know the person who's
receiving your test email your colleague
at work may be looking at that email on
their mobile phone and if it doesn't
look good to them they're going to let
you know some other ways to optimize
email content personalization so we did
that on the a b testing you always want
to personalize it question is hey do I
use first name do I use first and last
name well guess what you can test that
but you want to personalize it okay you
want to choose the right fonts and
colors for your email so when we were
going through some examples on testing
you know I always tend to go a little
bit larger on the font which you could
play around with it I don't think you
should probably use white lettering on a
black background that just is not very
good or best practice but go ahead and
try it if you want okay you can always
play around and test these but you want
to choose something that's really going
to resonate with the recipient of the
email okay you want to build a rapport
with customers by sharing insights they
value for example the beginning of this
webinar we talked about advocacy we
talked about you know sharing with them
some of the non-profits that we work
with as a company okay if we have a you
know Cosmetics company and we have
different products like moisturizers and
facial creams we may want to state that
hey we don't use any animals in the
testing of these products you know we're
pro-animal we're not you know we're not
going to use animals in the testing of
our products and that probably resonates
with a lot of your customers so you want
to bet go ahead and build a rapport with
those customers by sharing those
insights okay and use recipient names
and you always want to personalize it
then add a clear call to action at the
end you always want to have that call to
action regardless of what the email is
hey it could be just a simple read more
or hey donate it doesn't have to always
be so hardcore in terms of hey purchase
our product that could be a turn off
especially if you're sending emails out
once a week to your customer base
they're constantly hammering them with
buy now buy now buy now they're going to
get turned off so you want to mix up the
call to actions and that goes back to
the very first step and what kind of
email are you going to send out and who
are you going to send it to so you have
to align those two if it's somebody who
doesn't even know who your brand is
you're not going to put a call to action
of buy now you're probably going to say
hey check us out we have some cool stuff
for you okay let's talk about automating
emails email automation so triggered
emails are sent to customers based on an
event date or user Behavior okay so when
we say an event could be a special
occasion like Mother's Day okay it could
be a date like a birthday or anniversary
or a specific day that a week can also
be based on user Behavior you know a
good example of user Behavior are those
who abandon the car you can trigger an
email in fact MailChimp has remarketing
functionality so with my MailChimp hey
if somebody abandons our car we can have
an email triggered and we could send an
email a nice email that says hey we
noticed you didn't finish purchasing our
product and I'm not sure what happened
but hey here's another 10 off or you can
always just make product recommendations
as well but you want to react to user
behavior and use emails to your
advantage for that so you want to take
be cognizant of different occasions you
want to be cognizant of special events
holidays
Etc and user Behavior so these types of
emails can be automated because you know
when they might happen or that they are
probably going to happen so
autoresponder emails are sent at
frequent intervals based on the behavior
of subscribers so for example people if
somebody purchases something then you're
gonna get an email that probably says
hey thank you for your purchase another
email that says hey your product's on
its way and then another email that says
hey your package your product has been
delivered so that's an example of an
automated email that goes out if
somebody purchases your product you
probably want to thank them for that and
then you probably want to let them know
that hey it's on its way here you could
track it and then again you want to
confirm that it's been delivered but
thank them again so that's an example of
an automated email that goes out okay
let's talk about types of email
campaigns so we have different types of
email campaigns and the first is a
newsletter so with email newsletters
subscribers are connected and informed
about product updates so it doesn't
necessarily have to be a product they
buy it could be a product they subscribe
to like software okay you always want to
be able to send out that newsletter to
let them know what's going on with your
product effect are there upcoming
product updates ahead is there one that
just happened is there a webinar that
discusses the new product update so
that's what the newsletter is going to
do inform the end user about the update
so how to optimize okay so you stack
your email content create a compelling
header share different variety of useful
content like videos articles Etc with
those recipients and then follow a
consistent schedule so that's how you
handle a newsletter you should always
create a compelling header but if you're
going to send out a newsletter make sure
you support it with some good
information like a video that they can
go watch or an article that will follow
up on what you put in the email or
promoting that webinar that's going to
talk about that product update so
example here is a newsletter that gets
sent out and here you can see it talks
about business process it's got some
nice imagery in there okay call to
action it's got a little bit of
everything in this email template okay
okay and that's when we talk about stack
your email content that's what you talk
about stacking you can see at the top
it's got work with the industry best
subscribe now okay they validate that
with 25 years of taught not service then
they talk about hiring the best talent
and you got the next bit of content
below that so that's stocked email
content okay that's going to be
supported by compelling header and then
they're gonna share a variety of
different content in there like there
could be Clicks in there to video videos
and articles moving on from newsletters
to promotional emails so we want to be
able to drive Revenue by sending special
offers through promotional email okay so
how do we optimize a promotional email
well we want to personalize the campaign
okay promotional we want to definitely
personalize it include time sensitive
offers we want to get people to react
okay so that means you know adding a
sense of urgency in the title and the
subject line okay you can send offer
emails on holidays if it's Mother's Day
hey send it a couple days before or even
send it on if it's personalized then you
can say hey so and so we know you're a
mother here take 20 off I mean that kind
of personalized email with an offer goes
a long way here you an example from
Tom's limited time extra 20 off all
styles they include the code in there
okay again you can see the the
sensitivity and the sense of urgency
with the limited time another email
campaign type and personally one of my
favorites is abandoned cart so abandoned
card emails I like working with
abandoned card emails because you know
we want people to purchase and as much
as you try on your email marketing
campaign to drive traffic to the website
and as hard as the website works to get
people to convert through the shopping
cart it's never gonna be a hundred
percent and so abandoned cart emails
give us us that extra incentive to get
that person back to the shopping cart to
purchase okay so these emails are shared
with customers who have added product to
their cart but didn't finish through the
checkout process in other words they
didn't purchase the product so it's an
effective way of sales recovery it gives
us another opportunity to reach out to
that person who just is almost there but
not quite ready to finish the purchase
so what are we going to do we're going
to send out an email for those that
abandon their car and we're going to use
a simple abandoned card email template
okay you want to be simple here you
don't want to get complicated we're
trying to make this easy for them to
finish purchasing the products and we
want to definitely personalize it okay
we want to send a series of email
reminders okay in your email reminder
add a product image so as customized as
it can be it could be even the product
image of what they've abandoned and
that's the best practice so if it's that
facial moisturizer that Linda's trying
to promote and she can't quite get
enough people to finish purchasing the
product they're they're banning the cart
well she can certainly send out the
abandoned cart email okay so for example
you want to personalize it hey you
forgot to complete your order you left
something in your car can we help email
too hi there so and so items in your
shopping cart are selling out quickly
it's a gentle reminder okay so come
across a little bit different here okay
email three hey so and so 20 off on your
cart valid until so and so offer on your
favorite product so the first email that
went out and the series of emails it's
hey you forgot something hey is there
anything we can do to help you complete
the product purchase email two is just
that gentle reminder hey we're selling
out quickly you might want to purchase
that product an email 3 is to really
help them along by saying and hey here's
20 off valid until so and so so it's
just a small series of emails that go
out try and get somebody back into the
shopping cart okay let's talk about
re-engagement campaign so on a
re-engagement campaign it's a series of
emails sent to an active email
subscribers so what it does is it boosts
engagement and helps to maintain a high
inbox placement ratio inbox placement
ratio so we want to be able to make sure
that we're getting people back on a
subscriber list so how are we going to
optimize for something like this this is
now these are difficult type of email
campaigns we're trying to re-engage with
people who are inactive so we want
gamification to re-engage subscribers or
we want to prefer subject lines like hey
we've been missing you or did we do
something wrong okay we can run a poll
or competition to re-engage with our
subscribers so for example hey we'd hate
to miss your your birthday go ahead and
update your account this is a Starbucks
email so we'd hate to miss your birthday
so it's that you know message of missing
you you can always soften or sweeten the
deal with an offer as well so that
brings us to how to engage with new
subscribers so we just talked about
re-engaging with inactive we want to
talk about engaging with new subscribers
so how to engage with new subscribers
well thank your subscribers for joining
okay create clear and compelling subject
lines that is a must regardless of what
type of email you send out you always
want to send out that compelling subject
line okay notice the good examples
within 17 to 24 characters know the
ideal time to message okay again sending
it on the weekends not gonna work okay
sending it out during the weekday you
know in the morning mid morning you know
sometimes in the afternoon work works
really depends on who your audience is
the weekends probably aren't going to
work they avoid the no reply Center name
again personalize it you're either Sam
or Rob or so and so Sally you know let
them know that the email is coming from
a real person okay because if it doesn't
come from a person most people aren't
going to respond okay we want to let our
subscribers know the privacy policy so
we want to let them know that we abide
by a privacy policy okay that's you know
getting you straight with people who are
new they don't know your brand they
don't know your privacy policy they
don't want to get spammed in other words
so putting that out there makes you more
transparent and trustworthy okay and
again personalization always personalize
if it's new if it's inactive repeat
customers loyal customers lifetime
customers you should always personalize
and you should always be courteous and
always thank them and then prefer
attractive email designs okay work with
something that's going to be eye-catchy
and then most important most important
is include an unsubscribe link I can't
tell you how annoying it is to get an
email and not have the unsubscribe link
there that makes me want to unsubscribe
even if it was a good email I still look
for that because maybe they're good
company but they're spamming me they're
sending me too many emails so maybe I
want to unsubscribe or change my
subscription so you always want to
include that unsubscribe Link in fact in
the United States it's actually law so
there is regulation about that around
that so you need to include an
unsubscribe link it's just common
courtesy if anything so it bodes well
okay of course you don't want people to
unsubscribe but you don't want them to
get annoyed either okay let's talk about
email marketing tools so we talked about
MailChimp so there are plenty of email
marketing platforms out there I use
MailChimp I've used a few in the past
like Marketo I've used Zoho vertical
response so there are a lot of different
tools out there here some of them again
MailChimp Marketo Marketo is a marketing
automation tool or system and Marketo is
good for sending those automated emails
HubSpot convert kit send in blue aweber
I mean these are just some of the many
that are out there okay so let's show a
demo again of an email marketing
campaign so let's Show an example of a
newsletter that one of my clients had
sent out and so this is Paul Ackman
group Paul Eckman Dr Ekman inspired the
TV show lie to me so well known in the
industry of micro Expressions he's the
form mentioned expert in micro
expressions and he sends out email
marketing campaigns and he sends out a
monthly newsletter so this is a
newsletter person out in November 2018
and if we look at it you can see here
okay it's stacked content nice imagery
okay respectful disagreements how to
deal with disagreements this holiday
season so really relevant personalized
because And Timely because it was set in
November during the holiday season so
got some nice imagery there okay we got
content in here and then right below
that on the stack content what do we
have final hour 24 hours 25
off so that sense of urgency built into
the email then here you go you have some
other content in there based on the face
of contempt okay just an example of a
micro expression and then right below
that what do we see we see a call to
action learn how to use micro
Expressions to your advantage so call to
action here then we have some more
information here with the learn more so
a newsletter that went out basically
really a blog post built into the email
with some nice content reminding folks
hey they have 24 hours got some other
useful information in the email so this
email went out very timely 98 000 okay
see subject line here controversy
respectful disagreements and
Thanksgiving okay could the subject line
be a little bit shorter yes possibly but
if we look at the open rate 15 16 open
rate okay industry average in Education
and Training is 18 okay so they're close
to the industry average on the click
rate you know 1.6 percent on the click
rate industry average 2.1 so we can see
what the top links were clicked okay so
they have a lot of links and and
MailChimp will help you measure what
links were clicked the most who
subscribed what subscriber with the most
opens we can see opens by country but
that's an example of a new newsletter
for this particular company okay stock
content okay sense of urgency okay you
can see the subject line timely
newsletter so this is a a good I think a
good example of an email for the time of
year okay so let's go over the checklist
again for email marketing so good
reminders on the checklist this is a
checklist you want to make sure all
boxes are checked you want to create
interesting subject lines as they boost
your open rights direct correlation with
open rates is subject line okay you want
to keep your content relevant and
consistent with your brand you want to
check the sender name okay so you want
to make sure not only these are
personalized but the name aligns with
the email address okay should always
personalize always personalize the
subject line and the email copy text
meaning you know don't just say hello
say hello to Sally Pete Rob Michael
Etc always include an unsubscribe Link
in emails okay give people the option to
unsubscribe okay you can always
re-engage them another way or later on
but you don't want to irk any one of
your potential customers use a b testing
we talked about a b testing the webinar
there's lots of different elements we
can test from subject line to content to
font to call to action to imagery to
subject line Etc there's no shortage of
elements in an email you can test you
want to use welcome emails to build good
customer relationships so when somebody
signs up for a newsletter send out a
welcome news email to them hey welcome
thank you for signing up you should
always segment your list based on user
Behavior so you have a group of people
who purchase product a customize your
email for product a but you know you can
mention product b and c in there but no
know who your audience is so you can
talk to your audience and you can always
ask your subscribers to update their
preferences as well because you want to
make sure you're sending out emails to
the right person right address okay this
is a a short checklist now we can expand
upon this but these are some of the most
of the key items when it comes to email
marketing some other items on the
checklist include features such as
countdown timers and live polls okay
make it interactive okay choose the
right email frequency don't be sending
emails three or four times a week and
once a week is probably as much as you
want to go depending on what it is if
somebody purchases something then you
probably want to send an email thanking
them for the purchase another one
letting you know the product has been
shipped and another one with thank you
the product has been received reward
those subscribers send out exclusive
offers okay make sure your emails are
optimized for more mobile that means
send out test emails and check it on
different devices okay create a schedule
okay you can automate these emails so
create a schedule that makes the most
sense have a footer and a header in the
email and in that footer and header is
going to be some information okay just
like I showed you with the micro
Expressions there was a footer and
header avoid spam filters okay how do
you avoid spam filters well apply best
practices they don't have spammy subject
lines have an actual name associated
with the reply to email and and split up
your list as well when you send out one
email to 150 000 people it could
probably get caught up in some spam so
segment out your audiences keep your
audience list short so that your
messaging can be specific to the
audience that's going to help avoid spam
and then of course you always want to
measure and analyze results so remember
a lot of these email marketing platforms
have the results built in especially
open rates and click rates we're going
to talk about MailChimp so we're going
to go through the features and benefits
of using MailChimp as your email content
platform so buckle up and let's get
started with MailChimp so the first
thing you need to do is sign up for an
account with MailChimp and that simply
just providing an email address an ID
and a password and I recommend when you
actually sign up for an account you sign
up with a free plan first and let's take
a look at what the feature plan features
are for MailChimp so I'm recommending
the free plan but when you actually sign
up you have the option to actually pay
for a plan so you have the essential the
standard the premium or the free and so
I recommend you go with the free version
first it's like buying a car you want to
test drive it out see if you like it see
if you like the features and benefits
and you can see here that with the free
plan you get a lot of features and
benefits so you get all the basics for
businesses that are just getting started
so if you're just getting started with
email marketing I would recommend the
free plan here because you have a 2 000
contact maximum so that means you can
send out an email to your 2000
recipients free of charge so not a bad
deal for businesses who are starting out
I mean if you are prepared you've used
MailChimp before then go ahead and sign
up for one of the paid versions each
version has a different set of Standards
a different set of features and benefits
from the essential all the way up to the
premium where you're going to get you
know Advanced features
um and more customization but that's 299
dollars a month so if you're not
prepared to pay that amount then my
recommendation start with that free plan
now when you actually do set up your
account you're just gonna again provide
a ID a email address and password you're
going to go through a couple of steps
and one of these steps that I would
recommend you do right away is connect
your Facebook and Twitter accounts so if
you already have a Facebook and Twitter
account very simple all you're doing is
authorizing MailChimp to connect to the
account and the reason for that is when
you actually connect your Twitter
Facebook account you'll be able to then
you know share content on those
platforms and MailChimp will do that for
you automatically okay so here you're
just asking it to more or less interact
with the platform social platform and I
recommended doing that as you're going
through the setup process very simple to
do if you're already logged into your
Twitter Facebook account all you need to
do is click on the plus Button as you go
through the setup Wizard and authorize
MailChimp to access your Twitter or
Facebook account here you can see what
mailchimp's going to be able to do
they're going to be able to read tweets
from your timeline post tweets for you
on your behalf if you want them to if
you want them to you're going to allow
MailChimp to see create and manage your
advertising data including the campaigns
and audiences and the reason for this is
you may you know want to integrate your
email marketing efforts with your social
media efforts and the great thing about
MailChimp is hey look if you want to
post content on these platforms you'll
be able to if you want to leverage other
benefits from Facebook and Twitter and
integrate them with MailChimp you'll be
able to so having these two Platforms in
the case of Facebook and Twitter talk to
MailChimp is a positive because then
you'll be able to do a little bit more
get your message out there a little bit
more so I highly recommend you take this
as a necessary step when you're going
through the setup now it's optional you
don't have to but I recommend it now
when you're actually setting up your
account you're going to be asked to you
know design a template okay so you could
pick a template just by default you
could pick one just to get the account
going but you can always go back and add
or change out the template so here you
can see I'm in the setup wizard but I
arbitrarily just chose a template I can
go back and choose some of the templates
that are available to me now I can't
even create your own template if you
want to okay so you just click create
template and you'll be you know asked to
choose kind of a you know template that
you can pretty much change and customize
so if you're thinking about sending out
an email with an announcement then
that's the type of template you want to
choose and so here now you can see we
have a logo we can change the
announcement here we can add photos
Etc so if I want to add my logo I'm just
going to go up to this top portion here
click the little pencil icon that'll
allow me to edit here you can see it's
the default logo I don't really have a
logo so I can say replace it I can also
link to it and here you can see in the
content Studio MailChimp I don't have of
any images to choose from so I'm going
to go ahead and upload one and I'm going
to go ahead and upload my logo that I've
had on my desktop okay so it's going to
upload and now I can select that and
insert it so now I have my logo as part
of my template here and you can also see
you can add some styling here to this
hot header part so I can add a nice
border around that okay so I can align
It Center I can go edge to edge okay so
I can customize the image in this
particular template here so I'm just
going to click save and close now I'm
ready to move on to the next part which
is just click on edit I want to make an
announcement okay share your big news
okay we're we're having a launch party
okay so here you can see again just in
this template these quote unquote
announcement template I'm able to just
make changes to each section now I'm in
the section of the announcement part
where I can now customize the text and
you can see I can you know both it you
know I can choose a different font go
Ariel I can choose the size you can make
it smaller larger pretty easy to use
like it's again style it with different
color and so I can make multiple columns
here if I want to so there's a lot you
can do just in this one section as well
so let's go ahead and just do one more
thing here let's Maybe cover it or
something I mean you can see I can add a
link let's go ahead and make it blue
that's the background so I want to
change the background so I'm just going
to click Ctrl Z I'll change the color of
the font itself there you go very simple
and easy to use now I can add photos
here if I want to so let's go ahead and
add this bottom part here so I'm going
to click again the edit icon okay so
here you can see I have three images in
the template I'm going to go ahead and
add to that so here I can go ahead and
upload some files so I have some files
waiting for me on my desktop I'm just
going to go ahead and add them and
upload them to the content studio and
now that I've uploaded them I can select
one of them to insert okay now I'm going
to go here insert the second one and now
I'm going to grab the third one and
insert that in its place here you can
see now I can go ahead and you know
style each one of these if I want to
okay I can add a border again okay I can
go ahead and do rounded Corners okay
settings you can see how I can set it up
this so they're all vertical I can do
this so I have a lot of flexibility
and what I add to these particular you
know templates okay this is again just
the announcement template and so now I'm
going to click save and close and here
you can see I can add some other things
to it if I wanted to I could play around
with the design and header and once I'm
done really if I'm happy with my email I
can just close it out and I'm done so
what I could do now is when you're done
with this template you can just preview
and test it so I could send a test email
or enter preview mode so if I enter
preview mode this is what the template I
chose is going to look like if I happen
to send it out okay this is what it
looks like on desktop this is what it
looks like a mobile and if I go inbox
preview I'll need to upgrade my account
because I'm on the free version so but I
can certainly see what it looks like on
mobile on desktop so I'm just going to
click out of that and this is a template
and so I can go back and edit this
anytime I want so when I'm done I'm just
going to go ahead and click the
MailChimp icon in the upper left it's
going to ask me to name my template so
I'm going to name this the announcement
template I'm going to click save and now
it's in my templates so I am free to use
this template anytime I'm ready to send
an email okay and again I can you saw
how easy it was to make a change in the
template itself so when I'm ready to use
the template I can just go ahead and
grab grab it okay and again I can go
ahead and style it and design it any way
I want so you have different sections of
the page that you can style and here you
got you know mobile style designs if you
wanted to now if you wanted to in the
template if I want to like duplicate the
whole block I can duplicate that whole
block and you can see it just copied it
or I can just get rid of it to very easy
to use wysiwyg if you will or interface
it allows you know MailChimp allows from
some easy you know functionality easy
features to go ahead and manipulate and
change to your liking okay so again I'm
working with a template here so anytime
I'm ready to use that template for an
email I can go in and start using it
okay and if I go to templates again I'm
going to find my template here I can
always edit it I can always share it I
can always preview it I can replicate it
and that's the important thing so if I
replicate it I'm basically creating a
copy of it okay so I just created a copy
so now if I wanted to create a or change
the copy of of it I can do that so if I
don't like this whole block I can just
delete it and now that I'm done I can
rename this I'm just going to say
announce the template V2 so now it's
been renamed and now I have two
templates just simply by choosing one
and replicating it so again if I go back
to templates here here I go I have my
two templates and I can store these in a
folder so I'm going to add a folder I'm
going to call it announcements and I'm
going to add the folder and that's it so
now I can store these in the folder so
you can organize all your templates in
different folders if you want to so I'm
going to take these two templates here
move them to my announcements folder and
there you go there in the announcements
folder so if you're going to create
multiple templates then I would
recommend you go ahead and organize it
create folders you know and set up as
many folders as you want and need
because you're going to probably have
different templates for different
occasions depends on what type of email
you're sending out so I just chose
arbitrarily an announcement type email
so now if I go back to create templates
okay you can see again let's go through
some of these others again I just chose
make an announcement you can tell a
story follow-up educate you got all
sorts of different templates that you
could choose all sorts and here you got
some themes so you can even go with a
theme if you wanted to so for example if
you're selling products let's just say
you have a boutique store let's just
choose this Boutique template if I
choose this here is my themed template
and so now just like the other template
I I was working in I can go ahead and
edit this here you can see at the top I
got the middle section you know I got
all these different sections that I can
now go ahead and edit so just about
really it's about choosing the theme
template that works best for you and
feel free to you know try these
different templates out and see what
works best for you so here you can add
in certain things like you know social
share so if I just drag and drop I can
add in a social share image card so a
lot of these themes are very flexible in
what you can do in terms of the design
in terms of the content so again if you
go back and I'm going to cancel and not
save this temp well let's save it we'll
call it Boutique we may use it again in
the future so I'm going to go ahead and
click save and now it's a template it's
going to be located in templates and
again if you always want to access
templates just go to templates you'll
see the templates that you already have
created and added so you can edit them
always just by clicking the edit button
now that's again if you want to create a
new template just create click on the
create new template call to action again
you got themes you've got layouts or you
can even create your own from scratch
you can import another template that you
created in another email marketing
platform or you could do simply just do
everything from scratch in HTML so you
have three different options here
layouts themes and creating a template
on your own okay and that's either by
importing or by creating it from scratch
okay my recommendation I like some of
the layouts that MailChimp has you can
see a lot of flexibility here and when
you actually choose one again you're in
full control of how to design and
message it so you're in full control of
that so if you just want it again tell a
story I'm going to select this template
here okay now I'm on the free version so
keep in mind with the free version I
don't have access to all the templates
so here I get an upgrade to use this one
but for example if I don't see the
message upgrade to use then I'm free to
grab it so you can see the one column
I'm free to use so I'm just going to
select that and now I have this template
available to me so again I'm free to
edit this one as I see fit I mean I can
go ahead and again drop in any one of
these elements that are available to me
here I'm going to drop in my social
block okay so here you can see I can now
customize my social blog if I want to
add in another platform form I can do
that social media platform click save
and close so you can see they're very
customizable all of these themes and
layouts are very customizable and again
when you're done it's just a matter of
you can preview it or test it you can
enter preview mode or you can send
yourself a test email okay if you send
yourself a test email you can actually
see how it looks when it comes in so
let's go ahead and do that here so I'm
just going to send myself a test email
and the email has been sent so let's go
check our inbox so here is the email
that I just created from the theme you
can see here all I did simply when I
edited I just dropped in my social Block
in here so this is what the email looks
like and the great thing about MailChimp
is they have an option that you can view
the email in a browser if you can't or
you know don't want to look at it in
your in this case I'm looking at gmail
so you can always or recipients can
always view the email in a browser
versus the email client that they're
using in specific now when it comes to
completing your profile on MailChimp
you're going to need an audience to send
these emails to and so when you click on
audience here if you don't have an
audience already imported into MailChimp
you're going to be asked to import so
you can see I already have one contact
that contacts me because I added my
email address on that test email so
MailChimp smart enough to say okay we
don't have this email address and our
contact list so we're going to add them
so here we could see we can manage our
audience so we can add subscribers we
can import contacts we can have sign up
forms and we can manage our contacts so
if we import our contacts if I click on
import here I'm going to be asked to
import either from a CSV or copy and
paste or I can just go ahead and
integrate it so if I choose for example
any one of these then it's going to pull
in the contacts I have there and so it's
up to you how you import your contacts
now the whole point of context is you
want to probably or really not probably
it's a best practice to actually create
different lists so that you can use
different audience lists with different
emails and so here you can see I have
one email address I can again import
contacts or I can add them individually
so I can ask subscribers here okay
that's another option that's the slower
option my recommendation be import them
but when you import make sure you your
importing lists that have some
commonality so you can manage those
lists so if you have one list that are
say you know clients who have never
purchased then you want to create a list
for them if you have clients who have
purchased separate those out okay so
that's the way I would go about it now
if you're trying to build a list
MailChimp has what they call sign up
forms so you have different forms that
you can embed and or have as a pop-up
and when people add their email address
to that form then it's automatically
going to get added to your MailChimp
account so that's a great feature in
MailChimp that allows you to you know
build out your audience just by using
one of their forms so again we have a
subscriber pop-up you've probably seen
some of these on some of the websites
you've gone to so you can customize it
and if you want somebody to subscribe to
your newsletter for example all they
need to do is enter in their email
address and click subscribe okay that's
the the pop-up version now again you
have the opportunity to you know use
other forms as well so you got a form
Builder here or an embedded form okay or
you're going to integrate the form okay
so if I click form Integrations here I
can use wufu or Squarespace I can
integrate with them if I go back to sign
up forms if I choose form Builder here I
have a sign up form and then I can
customize that form with different boxes
okay or Fields okay so whatever field I
want somebody to add information to I
can have that in there and then this
form could be you know on your website
so that's a great feature about
MailChimp is it helps you build an
audience so I can add this form to my
website and anybody who fills out that
form is going to be added to my
subscriber list that I can use for
future emails to take that a step
further I can even go from building a
form to building a landing page so here
you can see if I click on audience I can
go ahead at the bottom right here I have
an option to create a landing page so if
they click on that just like everything
else in MailChimp it's fairly easy to
use I'm just going to name it test click
begin here I can choose my audience
again I can what audience do I want to
add these emails to I click begin and
I'm going to accept and here now I have
all these different templates that I can
use as a landing page so if you want to
use these landing pages to collect
emails and those emails are going to be
added to your audience then you have a
nice selection here at your disposal
okay so here here I'm just going to
choose one you know grow my list okay
this is a landing page so I can
customize it just like I do with my
email template I can add my logo okay I
can start adding different fields here
like an image I can drop an image here
okay I can go ahead and you know drop in
my social shares okay I can drop in a
box text box okay and then I can start
customizing it with some text some
imagery you know some other information
again this is a landing page that I can
then add to my website and so anytime
somebody goes to the landing page and
fills out their email address and hit
subscribe it's going to be added to that
audience list and then I can turn around
and send an email using one of
mailchimp's templates to that audience
so MailChimp really does a great job of
allowing you to grow your list within
your own website via a landing page a
form submission or or form or pop-up so
there are lots of different options
available to us so I'm going to click
save and close here and now this landing
page is available to me so I can
customize the URL I can edit the
audience that these emails go to I can
add a page title and again I can edit
the design so I can really make this an
integrated part of my website by
designing it so it fits the feel and
look of my website I can add a specific
URL and I can add a nice page title to
it so MailChimp again does a great job
of just making it so easy for you to
build out a landing page for you to use
on your website to collect email
addresses so if you're doing a
pay-per-click campaign on Facebook or
Google you can actually Drive traffic to
these landing pages and get people to
fill out a form submission and when they
fill out the form submission that email
address is going to get added to your
audience that's an option or you can
just add it as part of your website and
people who go there from say organic
search can find that page and add their
email address or organically so that's a
great thing about the audience feature
and MailChimp and that not only can you
select an email template but you have
options to grow your audience okay again
importing contacts you could simply just
add contacts you can add you know a form
submission via pop-up a regular form
fields to your website or you can add a
landing page so it's important to note
that in MailChimp if you go to the
content Studio that's where you're going
to find all the files that you've added
to all your templates or landing pages
that you used before so if I click on
content Studio here here you can see the
files I've added to my templates if you
have products you can add your products
here okay so if you have an e-commerce
store you can certainly add your
products and then those products can be
used on your landing page or your email
templates you have something called a
giphy you can insert these into any of
your emails make it fun exciting
engaging here you have Instagram so what
you can do is you can integrate you know
any one of your Instagram accounts if
you have multiple accounts or if you
have one instagram account you can
integrate that one instagram account in
with your MailChimp account and when you
do that it's going to pull in all the
images that you've had on Instagram and
then you have an opportunity here just
to add a logo okay so you can use any of
your Instagram images within your emails
use one of these cool giffies again you
can import your products that you can
use for your email templates or just
keep tabs on all the files that you've
added before just by clicking on my
files now when you get to the point of
of building different audience lists and
sending out emails you're gonna have the
option to look at reporting to see how
those emails perform for those specific
audiences now again an audience is a set
it's like a segment you know these are
set of individuals who are going to
receive a specific email so in this
example you can see I have different
audiences and if we look at say any one
of these audience or even just go to all
audiences we'll be able to see how we
fared on some of our emails okay so for
example if I send out an email here in
April and this is April of 2019 I could
see how many total subscribers I've had
now along with the number of subscribers
you have you have what we call open rate
and click-through rate now we explain a
lot of the reporting and the specific
email metrics and another recording that
we did last week so if you're interested
in learning more about some of the
metrics then check out the video that we
have on YouTube email marketing tutorial
uh we recorded this last week go into
details about all the different metrics
you uh can learn about with email
marketing so take a look at this video
email marketing tutorial it'll be a nice
precursor to the MailChimp tutorial so
to give you some insights as to what
metrics to really pay attention to with
email marketing but in MailChimp we know
we can look at the total number of
subscribers we know that we have how
many opens and we know what the open
rate is and again the total number of
clicks and what the click-through rate
is okay so with MailChimp very easily
you just hover over it you get the raw
number and then the percentage so open
rate is how many people actually open
that email based on the total number of
people that the email was sent to so
here we can see in this particular email
last year in April you know we've had 14
14 1.1 percent to be exact and that is
thirteen thousand three hundred seventy
seven divided by ninety seven thousand
four sixty nine so that's how many
people open the email to thirteen
thousand out of ninety seven is about
fourteen percent now when somebody opens
it we hope they're going to click on it
and so here we got a 1.4 click-through
rate again that's the total number of
clicks based on the total number of
subscribers or people that were sent the
email and so MailChimp just gives you a
nice overview of how many subscribers
were in this particular audience list
and then the open rate and click right
so we can really dive in here and we can
actually see how that particular email
performs so we just pick one email here
we can just click view report we have
other options here we can print we can
download we can share it the whole
campaign or just view the email if we
want to view what the email look like we
can select that so we just want to view
the report so we're going to click view
report 4 and now we can get into some
nice detailed information about the
actual report itself so again here you
can see total number of recipients and
this came from the audience list called
newsletter okay it was delivered last
year September 26 2018. again I have the
option to view it download it print it
or share it so let's take a look and
view the email to see what it looked
like okay so this is what the email
looked like we have our own template
here and here you can see it takes into
account some of the best practices
involved with email marketing you know
we have some nice content imagery some
call to action here some other links
okay we have our social icons okay so
that's what the email look like okay so
we'll go back and we're going to click
view report now we want to view the
report again here's what it looked
here's when it was sent okay the open
rate for this was 21 click-through rate
was four percent so for us the list
average this list here new newsletter
the average was for the open rate 16.8
percent so we're above the average on
this email for the click-through rate
the list average is 2.7 so we're above
the average so we've done a good job on
this email at least generating more
opens more clicks and MailChimp even
takes that a step further they'll even
show you what the industry average is
for your particular industry and in this
case for Education and Training so we
did better than the industry average for
both the open rate and for the
click-through rate so we could see some
other specifics we could see the raw
numbers of opens clicks how many people
bounce meaning the email address wasn't
valid anymore and so MailChimp does a
good job of any email that actually
bounces it'll be scrubbed and removed
from your list and then here you can see
347 unsubscribed so the the thing about
you know MailChimp is we want to be
careful we don't have too many
unsubscribes and also people abusing or
reporting abuse meaning you don't want
to say send out an email multiple
multiple times a week where it gets the
point where it's spammy and so you want
to avoid a high number of unsubscribes
and a high number of abuse reports and
so here you can see most emails are open
within a 24-hour period and then it kind
of just tails off so here we can see
opens and clicks based on the time of
day so within the 24 hour period okay so
this is how most emails operate within
that first 24 hours you're going to get
a lot of opens a lot of clicks and then
it's going to tell off from there great
thing is MailChimp provides me more
detailed information about what was
clicked so I could see here the top
links that were clicked and let me just
point one thing out here whether you use
MailChimp or you use any other platform
whether that be vertical response or any
other type of email marketing platform
you want to use UTM tracking with your
links so that Google Analytics X can
pick up the actual campaign so here you
can see we have UTM tracking appended to
our links and let me just go in to
detail on that for just a minute so
MailChimp again gives us nice data on
open and click-through rates but when we
send out an email and people actually do
click on one of these links they're
going to go to our website and from
there Google analytics is going to take
over on the tracking so this is as far
as MailChimp goes so we want to be able
to bridge the gap between MailChimp
reporting and Google analytics meaning
when they came from the email email went
and went to the site did they convert
meaning did they download something did
they purchase something and so we want
to be able to bridge the gap and UTM
tracking which is simply appending the
original URL with some tracking
parameters named UTM it allows us to
bridge that Gap so all you need to do
when you set up a MailChimp campaign is
just go to URL builder in Google go then
you're going to click on campaign URL
Builder and we're going to go ahead and
set up an email campaign so for example
if we go back here this was the original
URL so if I just copy this original URL
here and paste that as part of my
website URL what's my campaign Source
I'm going to put MailChimp what's my
medium I'm going to put email so
MailChimp is the source of where the
traffic came from the medium the means
in which they arrived at our website was
via email and then the campaign name
we're just going to put maybe whatever
it is summer promo so with the URL
Builder you have five parameters for UTM
tracking you don't have to use all five
okay so here we need to put in the URL
and we need to put in the source but the
other four parameters medium name term
and content are optional so you don't
have to put anything there but the more
parameters you put in the more specific
it is for you to track the behavior of
that email campaign so here I can see
MailChimp email summer promo and then
for the content I can use that to
differentiate my subject lines so when
you send out an email we mentioned this
in the email marketing tutorial you
always want to send out multiple subject
lines meaning one list gets one subject
line another list gets this a second
subject line because you want to be able
to measure open rates based on subject
lines so I can use the campaign content
parameter for different subject lines
and notice the URL Builder once I enter
in my parameters it's going to append
the original URL with a new URL appended
with UTM tracking so if I copy that I
can simply just paste that in my browser
just to see if it works and here you can
see it works the page loaded the
original URL with UTM tracking and so
that's exactly what you want to do
because when you're looking at your
reports in MailChimp it's going to show
me the top links that were clicked now
if I go in analytics I want want to be
able to see how that campaign or how
that link actually performed so let's
take a look at that real quick so if I
go to my Google analytics account and I
go to acquisition campaigns all
campaigns what am I looking for well if
I click on source and medium source and
medium are to the parameters for UTM
tracking I'm going to look for MailChimp
so here I could see my original URL
MailChimp and then the date stamp and
then the mediums email so if I go back
here I Can See For example any one of
these meal champ emails that went out
and then I could see how many people
actually came from the email what the
bounce rate was meaning if they arrived
on the side did they leave after
arriving or do they actually go to
another page and then I could see other
engagement data like how many pages they
looked at did they how much time do they
spend more importantly did they convert
so that's the whole idea behind using
UTM tracking because with you team
tracking you can bridge the gap from
open rate click-through rate to behavior
on the website all the way through to
the conversion and that's what we want
to measure we want to measure did
somebody go from the email open it click
on one of the links go to the website
engage on the website and convert and so
that's the whole idea behind UTM
tracking because MailChimp and any other
email marketing platform is only going
to give you at most your open rates and
your click-through rates okay so here we
could see the top links clicked I see 4
000 recipients clicked on this email
they went to the site and now I need
analytics to kind of tell me the rest
and here I can see what subscribers have
the most opens and if I integrated
social I can see some social performance
and so that goes back to our original
setup so if you integrate your Twitter
account or your Facebook account you'll
be able to integrate that email in with
your Twitter and then from there I'll be
able to see you know tweet dates or or
how many likes for example and to top it
all off I can see how many people from
around the world clicked on the email so
that's reporting in a nutshell on
MailChimp reports are fairly easy to
look at you know all sorts of other
information like links specifically
links you can look at Social so if I
click on the social tab here if I
integrated myself so I can look at
Social reporting likewise for e-commerce
and notice analytics 360 I can integrate
Google analytics in with MailChimp if I
want to so I have all sorts of options
on my reporting so that's it for
MailChimp I mean it's fairly easy to
navigate you have all the campaigns that
you've sent out so if you just click on
campaigns I'll be able to see all the
campaigns I've set up and all the
campaigns that have been sent and
obviously the ones that have been sent I
can start looking at reports I can pick
and choose templates okay I can pick and
choose my audience and manage my
audience okay I can see what the growth
is for my audience again I have
different options to grow my audience
okay I can certainly add form
submissions landing pages sign up forms
I can import more contacts and I can
manage them through different lists
content studio is where all your files
are going to be located from the files
you've uploaded to e-commerce products
to get these to Instagram to my logo and
then you have reports and the reports
are there for you to measure the
performance of your email campaigns once
they've been sent so you can look at
them from reports or just from the main
campaigns view that's pretty much it so
if you're ready to go at it again click
that create button click that template
choose that audience you can go ahead
and send yourself that test email when
you're ready go ahead and send that
email off to your audience it's that
simple in MailChimp we're going to cover
marketing interview questions and
answers so thanks for joining again and
here's how it's gonna work so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
as soon as possible we're going to go
through a series of questions and I'm
going to answer those questions for you
so email marketing traditional digital
marketing channel it's been around a
while and you're going to be asked some
questions that are going to accomplish a
lot of things related to the delivery of
emails we all check emails on a daily
basis we all receive them sometimes
receive emails unsolicited sometimes we
sign up to receive emails sometimes
receive emails from friends sometimes we
receive emails where we're working or
previously have worked so most people
have an understanding of email however
as a marketer there's a little bit of a
Different Twist to it so we have to
understand the intricacies of how email
marketing works so you're going to be
out some questions and really the first
question here is what's the difference
between a hard and a soft bounce email
so if you're a digital marketer you're
in charge of sending out lots of emails
let's just say thousands or yeah I mean
it could be in the hundreds of thousands
of emails you're gonna get some bounces
and so you really want to know the
difference between a hard and a soft
bounce so a soft bounce just means that
the email message reached the
recipient's mail server but bounce back
is undelivered so think of it as
delivering actual mail to a post office
so it actually reached the post office
but it bounced back because maybe the
you know person's email box was full
maybe their account was temporarily
disabled or maybe the email server
wasn't necessarily able to handle that
email now hard balance is an email that
that is rejected because it's an email
when it happens when the email has been
permanently rejected so for example
maybe the the the account is no longer
valid and so let's look at some reasons
again as to why a soft bounce would
happen so for example the inbox is full
or the recipient servers down so reach
the post office but there was a problem
actually getting it into the hands of
the owner so to speak where the hard
balance a little bit different let's
just say that person is no longer
working their email has been deleted or
you the email has been blacklisted
somehow okay a Spam or something to that
effect so the email server is going to
identify that and it's not even going to
reach the recipient so a lot of
different ways in which an email may not
make its recipient so not the most
important thing to know here I just the
important thing to know is listen when
you send out an email you got to pay
attention to how many get bounced back
and so next question here what would you
do to improve the click their rate of
your email so click the rate is simply
how many people have seen your email and
how many people actually clicked on a
link in the email so if a hundred people
saw your email but only one person
clicked then it would be a one percent
click-through rate so we want to be able
to make sure we have a high clicked
array so remember emails are going to
people who likely signed up to receive
your email and even if they are
expecting email or they're not expecting
an email you still want to follow some
of these best practices here one is to
create a compelling subject line so you
want to make the subject line something
that people are going to notice take
note of or take an interest in and say
hey what's this all about that's pretty
interesting and open the email so use
preview text effectively obviously you
want to make your email mobile friendly
because most people look at their emails
on their mobile phones you want to
create engaging content okay so the
content that's in the email obviously is
going to have some links so so put some
strong call to action in there and
that's one of the bullet points down
below place a CTA where it's easily
visible so keep in mind mobile users
most people are going to check that
email on their phone so you want to make
sure you have compelling content with
good ctas in a visible location so
always check mobile as well as desktop
obviously in your emails you want to
make them as visual as possible don't
make them so text Heavy you can always
segment your emails meaning if you're
sending out an email let's just say to
100 people okay maybe you want to divide
it out boys or girls maybe older or
young maybe you know living in one part
of the country versus another part of
the country I mean those are examples of
segments so break up the email don't
send it to one mass email to everyone
that way you can personalize the email
if an email is personalized the chances
of somebody clicking on it are going to
be greater and then a B test your emails
and when we say A B test you know you
could send out the same email twice if
up one segment is going to say get one
version of the email the other segment
is going to get another version of the
email and what are the different
versions maybe the subject line so the
subject line is different on version a
versus version b or maybe a call to
action is different so you always want
to send out different versions of the
same email to a different segmented
audience that way you can actually see
which segment or which version got the
most clicks okay so next question here
is how to inform your customers about
company news and establish a
relationship with your target audience
okay so again how do you inform your
customers about what's going on in the
company and how are you going to
establish a relationship with that
audience who's receiving that email well
newsletters are always the best answer
here so somebody signs up for your email
let's just say they actually purchase a
product from you newsletters are a great
way to reach out to that audience to get
them to stay up to date with the latest
product or an improved version of the
product they purchased and then that way
they can come back and continue to
purchase the product so newsletters are
great way to reach out to your audience
and actually talk to your audience and
you're not talking verbally you're
talking to them via email so you send
out that email campaign maybe it's once
a month hey we noticed you bought this
product we have similar products just
like the one you bought or hey you know
if it's a software maybe hey we've we've
got upcoming updates to our software
make sure you go to the website and get
the updates or we have a new and
improved version so all these things you
want to communicate to your audience via
email that's going to get them to get to
the website and that's going to get them
to you know purchase more update upgrade
whatever so newsletters the way to go so
again some basic tips here you want to
create your newsletter with 90
educational and 10 promotional so
remember you're sending out a newsletter
to people who likely signed up up so
you're educating them about your
products always create interesting
subject lines you want whether they know
you or not you want to create the
subject line so somebody's going to
click on it so make sure you design your
emails appropriately okay so if you know
you're sending let's just say baby
products two mothers or expected mothers
in fact this is a real life example
because I used to work at a gap and Baby
Gap was you know one of the emails
groups I was responsible for so we
created an email template with softer
colors your yellows your your light blue
you know it wasn't black or dark red or
anything that's going to be you know
heavy we knew who our audience was and
we designed the template accordingly and
of course using compelling images so for
selling baby products you're gonna put
baby product images in there I mean it's
common sense but you'd be surprised you
gotta pick and choose your images
carefully especially if you're sending
to an international audience because
images can be misconstrued and just like
we mentioned with the click-through rate
you always want to have a clear CTA
always make sure you have a CTA in a
visible position because most people are
going to look at that email in a mobile
phone okay and then always make sure you
include your contact information in the
newsletter so somebody knows where to
find you how to contact you where to go
maybe they have a product they want to
return okay so you always want to put
that contact information normally it's
at the bottom of the email but these are
all best practices so here's some
examples okay we've got you know check
out the latest Cosmetics from our new
collections notice the image and notice
the call to action so you can see trendy
collections you know we got some other
products you may want to buy okay five
important skin care products that
everyone should have view more so you
always want to have that call to action
in a very visible place so Define
following metrics open right
click-through rate and response rate and
and forward rate so these are metrics
related to email marketing so you're
going to have to know what these are so
I already mentioned click-through rate
before when we talked about best
practices from improving the
click-through rate so for those of you
that remember what that is go ahead and
put that in the comment section below
it's just a little pop quiz for you if
anybody remembers click-through rate but
let's take a look at open right so open
Raise the percentage of the total number
of recipients who actually open the
email so if you send it to x amount of
people how many people opened it that
would be the open rate so how many
people open it but you're gonna take out
the people who balanced it whether it's
a soft bounce or hard bounce okay you're
not going to count those people so if
you have let's just say 20 people open
the email and you send it to a hundred
people then and you had nobody bounce
then it would be a 20 open rate Okay
click the rate again Pop Quiz it's just
how many people actually clicked on any
of the links in your your email and
that's just divided by the number of
emails you've sent out the response rate
okay so response rate is the percentage
of the total recipients who clicked on
the link of your email campaign and
actually completed an action so what is
that action well it could be downloading
something watching something purchasing
something so that's the response rate
similar to conversion rate if you're
working in a digital marketing channel
and you're driving traffic to the site
you want that traffic to do something
well it's no different in email
marketing we want people to take action
we're just going to divide that by the
number of emails delivered and that
gives you your response rate so let's
just say you did send in 100 emails you
did get 20 open it and of this 20 let's
just say one person went on a purchase
well you'd have a one percent response
rate and then a forward rate is simply
the forward rate refers to the rate at
which your subscribers share your email
uh with others friends family Etc and
you may have that as a call to action in
your email in fact that's a best
practice so it's just the number of
clicks on a share divided by the total
number of delivered emails and you're
going to multiply that by 100 to get the
percentage and so most email marketing
platforms do measure forward rate okay
let's take a look at how do we capture
inactive customers what you want to do
here is re-engage subscribers with
gamification opt for subject lines like
we have been missing you or did we do
something wrong you want to run a poll
or competition and re-engage their
subscribers again trying to get people
involved these first three are all about
getting people involved so personalize
your emails talk to that person as if
hey look I haven't heard from you in a
while how about coming back and taking a
look at our new products just as you
would a friend so a design always
matters especially knowing that you're
talking to customers who haven't been
active Okay this is a segmented audience
somebody who's inactive so you want to
have the right design design the right
message the right subject line that fits
with that customers and activity so you
want to try and do everything you can to
get that customer back and then you want
to follow a consistent schedule okay so
ideally when you schedule an email you
want to schedule the best time so you
have to know your audience obviously and
then you can always ask for feedback why
are they inactive why haven't they
purchased in a while so the whole idea
here from gamification like trying to
you know make a game out of it so make
it competitive to adding polls to really
personalizing it these are all things
that you can do to get your customers
back so what are the different ways to
segment buy a Persona so again when we
talk about segmentation we're talking
about taking a smaller piece the entire
pie so what's one way to break up that
pie if you will by Geography okay so
with geography you could Target your
audience based on that area and it could
not necessarily they have to be by a
part of the country it could be all the
way down to the province the state the
actual City the county okay if you live
in a small village okay all the way up
to the continent okay so think about how
you would break out the segment by
geography now obviously if you break it
out let's just say in the United States
to the southern part well the southern
part you know in the winter in the
United States the southern part is not
going to be as cool to say the northern
part so that should tell you hey if
we're going to send out an email in the
winter we're not going to use snow and
and blizzards as our theme we're going
to use probably a little bit of Sun so
breaking it out by geography helps you
understand where your audience lives you
also have demographic segmentation and
this is simply just age education income
gender you know where people work okay
nationality anything that's going to
identify that user so this is the best
way to segment if you know who your
audience is by income or gender I mean
you're talking to a group of like-minded
people if they're all the same age from
the same generation then you could talk
to them appropriately okay you're not
going to talk to an older person the
same way you would a younger person so
think about demographic segmentation
because it really helps you hone in on
your messaging and you have behavioral
segmentation so behavioral is based on
your audience's behavior have they
purchased before have they never
purchased were they searching for
something how long do they stay on the
site what products were they looking at
are they a lifetime customer so you can
look at behavior and decide how you want
to break out your emails by behavior and
this is a really good way if you're not
even sure who your audience is or where
they live and how old they are you could
certainly break out your Audience by
Behavior because you know who these
people are based on what they've done
previously because you're going to track
that information with analytics so you
know one way is obviously if somebody's
purchased that's a good way to segment
because you know these people believe in
you believe in your business believe in
your product so the way you can message
to somebody who's purchased before is
going to be different than somebody you
don't even know who they are if they
purchased or not okay so behavioral
segmentation to me is one of the easiest
things the easiest ways to segment your
email list how would you drive repeat
customers through email marketing for
the below scenario okay so this is a pop
quiz if you will again for those of you
that got click-through rate correctly
could have let's see if you can go two
for two here okay so if you know the
answer to this go ahead and comment
below but let's just say give a few
examples of subject lines to drive
engagement for audiences based on the
following so if I had an audience
between 20 and 30 years old that were
female and the product were sandals okay
what were some of your subject lines be
so I'm going to give you a minute to
think about that and put it in the
comment section below now remember this
is an interview based question so you're
going to have to think on the spot I'm
going to give you a minute but if
somebody presented that to you in an
interview you need to be able to you
know react fairly quickly and come up
with some really attractive subject
lines here okay so here you go here's
another one uh so give a few examples of
subject lines to drive engagement for 20
to 30 females for Footwear so you got
Friday sale coming up buy branded
sandals at the lowest price okay so I
like this one because it's got a strong
call to action bye here you go this is
even better because 50 off on branded
sandals and free shipping I mean who
can't beat free anything including
shipping and if it's 50 off I mean these
are key things so you're putting the
promotion and percentage off all in the
subject line so that's really going to
grab somebody's attention weekend seal
for women starts now okay with a little
emoji that never hurt parts so those are
all good subject lines they all tend to
work because they all have an element of
a best practice in there so here you got
you know the Friday sale coming up is
just giving people notice okay the
stronger call to action on the buy
you're putting the promotion in the
subject line and you know you're using
an emoji to really just drive home the
point so all these subject lines will
work and hey at the end of the day
remember you want to test your subject
lines okay moving on to the next
question speaking of testing what is a b
testing and give some examples of a b
testing okay so we talked a little bit
about a b testing with subject lines so
simply a b testing when it comes to
email marketing it's just a method to
analyze which of the two email campaign
strategies is most effective all right
you know you're going to do it based on
open right you can do it by saying click
rate you can do it based on response
rate okay remember you're putting one
version of the email against another
version whether that be the subject line
whether it be the content call to action
whatever so that's ideally what you're
trying to do you're trying to figure out
what works for your audience that's the
end goal for emo for a b testing and
email marketing what's going to work and
I would highly suggest you should always
do a b testing for subject lines always
so some of the variables that you can
test again subject lines okay you always
want to try if you got a promotion hey
Will the percentage off work likely it
will but let's test it up against
something else like you know a generic
word like discounts you can always test
the design you can always test the
personalization the preview text you
could try out images call to actions
exclusive offers what particular offer
is going to work okay so if you're
testing offers then obviously that's
going to be response rate for testing
ctas and that's going to be
click-through rate for testing subject
lines that's going to be open rate so
you want to be able to test different
elements of the email to figure out what
works and what doesn't work okay so how
to prevent email from getting into spam
so if you're an email marketer this is
your worst nightmare you don't want your
emails to get spammed so that doesn't
bode well for you so most email
marketing platforms like MailChimp or
Constant Contact measure spam so some of
the important ways to prevent this is
hey improve your open rate remember
going back to the first question second
question you want to have really good
subject lines here okay and you want to
segment your audience so if you're if
you know who you're talking to and you
have a cool subject line that's going to
get somebody to react and open and
that's going to prevent somebody from
spamming your email okay you can always
customize your from to make it look like
it's coming from in this case Rob
Sanders check if you have included an
unsubscribe link okay so give people the
option to unsubscribe they don't have
the option to unsubscribe they could
just report you as spam make sure your
emails work on different devices okay
you want to optimize your images for
email make sure they're not big big and
they don't fit on a mobile device okay
prefer more text and fewer images and
then avoid grammatical issues you want
to come across as professional you don't
want somebody looking at your email like
who sent this why are you sending this
to me I don't want to hear from you
again I'm going to spam you you want to
prevent that and that means a
professional looking email professional
content with a really good subject line
and some imagery to go along with that
hey you may just get somebody to open
that email and get them to convert
that's the idea behind it so these are
ways to prevent somebody from actually
spamming you and then what are the best
practices for email subject lines so the
subject lines of most probably the most
important element in email marketing so
we talked about that little pop quiz
with the sandals targeting 20 to 30 year
old women you know to me I like the
subject line with the 50 off so that was
a number in the subject line so people
can actually see hey wow I get a whole
50 that works better than than just a
discount okay remember one of those
other subject lines had an emoji so
don't be afraid and include emojis in
there for example when I send out emails
using you know during the Spring you
might want to use flowers perhaps to
signify hey it's spring Winter's over so
personalize the subject lines remember
that goes with segmenting so if you know
who your audience is your subject lines
can be a little bit more personal okay
so opt for title case subject lines okay
so instead of making a grammatical for
example okay you want to keep your
subject lines short and to the point
remember you want to say something
that's going to draw somebody's
attention if you make it long and drawn
out and boring then people aren't going
to open it develop a sense of urgency
like hey we got 50 off through Friday so
that's a little sense of urgency so
people know hey if it's Thursday I
better open this email and check it out
and again grammatical mistakes that goes
without saying you always want to
preview your emails before you send them
out so if you preview your emails before
you send them out have somebody else
obviously receive the preview they can
be another set of eyes for you to
prevent any mistakes but also give you
feedback on the imagery the design
Etc okay so these are all best practices
for good subject lines okay so subject
line is the most important element for
email marketing so just keep these in
mind subject lines and having good
subject lines is the way to get people
to open it and from there that's half
the battle somebody can open the email
then you've just set yourself up for
better performance I'm Greg charpo and
what is that I mean what we're going to
talk about in this first module of a
Content marketing Foundation course is
liberally content marketing uh okay what
is it so content marketing Is Not A New
Concept it's been around for over a
hundred years in fact one of the classic
Foundation stories of you know the birth
of content marketing goes all the way
back to the Michelin Brothers in France
and the Michelin Brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know a little refresher
right now
were two brothers who made pneumatic
tires and they were trying to sell them
along with an Innovative product at its
time called the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place France where frankly people
didn't like to get outside of Paris and
into the provinces because my God what
was worth going out there for you know
or Paris that's all Happening Here
and what the Michelin Brothers realized
is if they wanted to sell more tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther
than use them
so what did they come up with
the concept that really is the birth of
content Marketing in my book
was the Michelin guide
and the Michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the provinces
and the Michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two and three
star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads but guess what
to die for the Ratatouille oh you you
gotta have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way and since we're going
to give you a guide and you have to get
out of Paris in order to get there we're
going to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way uh which hotels
uh you might want to stay at overnight
and oh by the way just in case you have
to
how to repair a flat tire particularly
if it's a Michelin tire because it's a
Pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put Michelin on the
map why they weren't trying to sell you
more tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or tire repair I mean that was in there
but it was only a how-to article not
necessarily a feature and benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to Their audience about what
Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in 1900. was food
and by creating content
that got the audience to get into their
new Innovative automobile
and drive all the way out there into the
provinces for that absolutely remarkable
three-star restaurant
people got more Flats people had to
replace their tires but it was worth it
and oh by the way
Michelin sold my tires
so that that's a great story every time
you sort of
you know hit a pause and like well we're
doing content marketing and we need to
come up with a concept
back to the Michelin guide it's it's
great Foundation
let's go to a modern definition where
are we now in the 21st century
when it comes to content marketing
well you can read the slide here and
read the definition and some people like
reading definitions I'm not going to
read it to you but I am going to
highlight a couple of words in the
definition that I think are absolutely
critical to any definition
of content marketing
the content that you create needs to be
relevant
and it also has to be valuable
now if it's not relevant then you're not
actually meeting my needs or interests
you know and why would I be interested
in them and we've gotten way too tired
I'm screening out the commercial that
comes on
um you know trying to sell out snow
tires
and pardon me we live in Florida I don't
use those tires what the what the heck
is this commercial doing
you know interrupting what I'm watching
so relevance is important
relevance means that this content isn't
going to get screened out
and the valuable the valuable can can
work in a lot of different ways it can
be interesting
it can be useful
you know value is an interesting
proposition all by itself
but that's the key to content marketing
uh it's not just creating more spam
it's not just throwing more trash over
the fence and hoping something happens
this is something where if you've
created valuable and relevant content
you know what your customers will find
you that's a whole different kind of
proposition
I know there's some Skeptics who are
saying oh come on come on come on
content marketing is just a fancy new
name for social media marketing right
and the answer is well there is some
overlap and we're going to deal with
that in module three
but let me just be clear here
social media content is part of what
content marketing needs to create
but it can also create content for your
website and that's not the social media
it can also create content that your PR
people can share with
reporters or bloggers and that's not
normally considered social media content
and by the way all of that content can
be optimized so maybe it actually is
part of SEO not social media marketing
in fact that's the other place that
content marketing really overlaps
and it's not coincidental
it so happens that around February
2011 when Google rolled out the first of
its multiple versions of the panda
update
all of a sudden even seos started to pay
attention to content marketing why
because Google changed the rules and
what Google basically said is if your
content isn't valuable or relevant
you know what it's not going to rank
very well in our search angle for them
and all of a sudden people who had been
used to like putting keywords in the
right places
realized content matters I mean I've got
to actually tell stories that are
interesting I've got to create
information that's valuable uh
yeah you can make it relevant that's the
optimization part
but you know if you're trying to
optimize a piece of boring irrelevant
trash
God bless you good luck
so yeah content marketing
has grown it's like tripled in terms of
web search interest since the panda
update and then we're talking about
panda one of course there was Panda 2
Panda 3D Panda 4. I mean come on
Google is driving us in this direction
and so content marketing is pretty
relevant today
now one of the other things that people
in content marketing struggle with is oh
but you don't understand I do B2B
content marketing or I'm a small
business or pardon me I'm an Enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right
well possibly maybe on occasion
so let's just question that assumption
for a second
you know content marketing has been
around now long enough and enough people
have done it but some research has been
conducted
and it's been conducted against b2c
marketers and B2B marketers and small
business marketers and Enterprise level
marketers
and when they start asking key questions
like okay
we're going to try to determine what is
the difference between an effective
content marketer and an ineffective
content marketer
let's see the results
well first of all the most important
thing to Be an Effective b2c content
marketer
is you need a documented content
strategy
oh okay all right I mean people who are
winging it aren't as effective as people
who actually have thought about this and
written it down got it okay
no great Insight but you know
interesting to note
secondly they've got to have somebody in
charge who oversees content marketing
oh Lord does that mean we have to have a
reorg or maybe we just have to designate
somebody who reports to somebody else
whatever but guess what it really helps
if somebody is driving this process
third they've got to be using more
content marketing tactics than their
less effective peers
and this is not an argument more is
better this is just pardon me that's the
way the data falls out the people who
are actually more effective are doing
more different kinds of things
a broader range of tactics
and who knows maybe it's that broader
range that's part of the success formula
same thing is true with social media
platforms
the effective content marketers are
using more than the ineffective ones
and last but not least and this may be a
sort of a result of the first four
by gosh effective content marketers
generally have greater percentage
of the overall marketing budget in their
organization
wow okay
that's the b2c marketing for me but you
don't understand I I'm not a b2c
marketer okay
so let's take a look at the B2B content
marketing formula
guess what
you need to have a documented content
marketing strategy to Be an Effective
B2B content marketer you need to have
someone who oversees content marketing
strategy it helps if you are using more
tactics
and more social media platforms and
guess what you spend a higher percentage
of your overall marketing budget
on content marketing well that's similar
to the b2c content markers but you
understand B2B is different yeah there's
a couple small differences but guess
what overall the top five criteria
are similar
and when you get the small business
here's what you're going to see
same five criteria
and you're in an Enterprise I know the
world is different for Enterprises
actually not so much
so four different data points let's net
it out there's a pattern
and the pattern is I don't care what
flavor of content marketer you are you
can be b2c B2B you can be small business
you can be large Enterprise at the end
of the day there are five things that
you've got to focus on
if you want to be effective
we've already covered these and are
there differences between small
businesses and large Enterprises between
B2B and b2c well sure
but they're all at the margin
what's the downside if we don't do this
you know is anyone going to come in and
like whack us
and the answer is
um maybe not inside your boardroom
but it may happen on the next sales call
that one of your sales people makes they
may encounter someone I like to call the
man in the chair
and the men in the chair actually refers
back to a classic McGraw-Hill ad
campaign from I think the 1960s
but basically the guy in the chair asks
theoretically some questions from quote
maybe your sales person okay I don't
know anything about you I don't know
about your company I don't know about
your company's product I don't know
about your company's you know reputation
or anything about you and so what was it
you were going to try to sell me
and that's the downside of not having a
Content marketing program
content marketing has been around for
over a hundred years
but in the online world
customers are behaving in lots of new
ways and they're consuming content on
various kinds and types of devices
that changes things content marketing is
now about creating content that
consumers will engage with and act upon
not just read or listen to or watch
so in this introductory module we're
going to provide you with an
understanding of how content marketing
affects the decision-making process when
people are on the customer journey to
making a purchase and with a solid
content marketing strategy your
customers buying decisions
can actually happen faster you can
basically
shorten the decision-making process
and you can reach and expand to new
prospects so one of the things that we
hope that you're going to learn after
basically taking this module you should
be able to do the following first of all
you can Define content marketing and
other related Concepts secondly you
should be able to explain why content
needs to be relevant and valuable in
order for it to be effective third you
need to describe the overlap between
content marketing SEO social media
marketing
fourth you need to name five traits of
effective content marketers
and last but not least you need to
explain the benefits of content
marketing these are our objectives and
hopefully they're going to be your
learning outcomes
so content marketing Is Not A New
Concept it's been around for over a
hundred years in fact one of the classic
Foundation stories of you know the birth
of content marketing goes all the way
back to the Michelin Brothers in France
and the Michelin Brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know low refresher right
now
we're two brothers who made pneumatic
tires and they were trying to sell them
along with an Innovative product at its
time called the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place France where frankly people
didn't like to get outside of Paris and
into the provinces because my God what
was worth going out there for you know
or Paris that's all Happening Here
and what the Michelin Brothers realized
is if they wanted to sell more tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther
and use them
so what did they come up with
the concept that really is the birth of
content Marketing in my book
was the Michelin guide
and the Michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the provinces
and the Michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two and three
star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads but guess what
to die for the Ratatouille ugh you you
gotta have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way and since we're going
to give you a guide and you have to get
out of Paris in order to get there we're
going to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way which hotels you
might want to stay at overnight and oh
by the way just in case you have to
how to repair a flat tire particularly
if it's a Michelin tire because it's a
Pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put Michelin on the
map why they weren't trying to sell you
more tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or tire repair I mean that was in there
but it was only a how-to article not
necessarily a feature and benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to Their audience about what
Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in 1900
was food
and by creating content
that got the audience to get into their
new Innovative automobile
and drive all the way out there into the
provinces for that absolutely remarkable
three-star restaurant
people got more Flats people had to
replace their tires but it was worth it
and oh by the way
Michelin sold more tires
so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of
you know greetings everyone and welcome
my name is Rob Sanders from Simply learn
and today we're going to talk about
content marketing strategy so buckle up
and let's get right to it and we're
gonna get right into some of the best
practices some tips some methodology
some things you should be doing with
content marketing so right out of the
gate let's start talking about knowing
your audience okay so content is all
about writing for a particular audience
so it's just like speaking except when
we're speaking to somebody we're
speaking directly to them content is
very similar and so we have to be able
to know our audience ahead of time so
what you can do is collect demographics
of your target audience based on who's
coming to your website so you can get
that data in Google analytics under
audience email subscribers I mean who is
subscribed driving to your emails who do
you already have in your email database
and you can look at social media I mean
you look at Facebook you can look at the
people who are already connected to you
okay these are just some three three of
many examples you could be doing to
gather data on your audience okay you
have to know who your audience is before
you start writing you know for a
successful content marketing strategy
you really just need to know your
audience and basically you're going to
segment them based on their interests so
that content is going to be catered to
that audience okay so if it's lines that
like a specific you know product uh that
you offer or feature that's part of that
product that you offer then that's the
segment you're going to be writing about
so you need to collect your data on your
audience ahead of time then you're going
to segment that audience okay so you're
not gonna write content for everyone
because the shoe doesn't necessarily fit
for everyone one okay the shoe has to
fit for specific foot and in this case
we're talking about an audience we need
to be able to segment our audience out
and you could certainly segment them out
by age by gender by education level by
income by interest I mean these are just
some of the examples again it could be
new returning or new reusers versus
returning users it could be users who
are purchased from you in the past
versus users who haven't purchased from
you in the past it could certainly be an
age range it could be even going further
on interest level or a combination
thereof okay so for example you can get
that demographic information using
Google analytics you just got to go in
analytics under audience under
demographics you're going to see age and
age is broken out by age range and
they're gonna see gender so you're gonna
see a breakdown of gender and use that
to your advantage so if you're going to
you know write some content and you know
99 of your traffic is female the age of
18 to 24 then you know that contents May
catered accordingly so we could
certainly go to Facebook page insights
and get some really good demographic
data there because Facebook is all about
demographics okay so you could see
exactly you know how many fans you have
broken out by Man versus women and then
you can see again same thing as Google
analytics you could see an age range
breakout you could use Twitter analytics
I mean Twitter has share some really
good insights into education level so
you know if you're dealing with you know
highly sophisticated people who have
master's degrees or even higher or let's
just say even on LinkedIn you know that
majority of the people you're trying to
Target are c-level meaning CEOs or CFOs
or CMOS those You Know Chief marketing
officers or chief executive officers
then you're going to cater your message
a little bit different than say
mid-range managers or or you know even
high range managers or even VPS so use
your audience information that you
collect on these various platforms to
your advantage okay so let's jump into
number two we want to create high
quality content now I know this sounds
like a given but and I say but heavily
there's not a lot of high quality
content out there on the internet so
separate yourself first and foremost
always always always always create high
quality content it's going to result in
a lot of things are going to benefit you
you know one you're going to come across
as you know somebody who knows what
they're talking about and that's going
to help increase your brand awareness
okay when you increase your brand
awareness people know about you so it's
likely going to increase traffic effect
to your website or if you're on social
media you know if you produce good high
quality content people are going to
share that content okay so from an SEO
perspective it can improve website
ranking meaning if you have good quality
content you know and it's really focused
in on a specific topic or a certain set
of core words keywords then you're going
to rank improves website dwell time
meaning hey you've got good content
people are going to hang around to see
what else you have to offer okay so it's
no secret that you know good content you
usually leads to you know quality
engagement and then certainly last but
not least you can gain a lot of leads
here meaning hey somebody likes what you
have to say whether it's a video or blog
post or or infographic you know people
are going to become more interested more
engaged spend more time and that's all
going to funnel through to somebody
taking that next step in the funnel and
becoming more interested in your service
or even purchasing one of your products
so creating high quality content
involves brainstorming topics and terms
you know you got to do The Upfront work
due diligence is at work here so
brainstorm some topics use a keyword
research tool to gather results so if
you have a topic you know one of the
benefits of quality content is rankings
go to Google's Keyword Planner
understand how much quality and and
understand how much competition each
keyword has or understand how much
volume each keyword has that's what's
available in Google's Keyword Planner or
any really any keyword planning tool you
always want to create original content
okay so you don't want to plagiarize or
take somebody else's content and then
you want to support that content with
compelling headlines so if you have a
piece of content you got to get
somebody's attention write a nice
headline that's going to grab their
attention Okay so give value able
content generators and add resources
from well-known sites so if you you do
borrow say a data point from another
source then you know cite that Source
you also want to create engaging and
thought-provoking content get somebody
to think I mean people are going to rage
your content because they not they don't
know the subject matter their interests
in the subject matter and they want to
be able to spend the time taking
something away from that content follow
a logical structure and use relevant
images I can't stress this one enough
you know just throw things on a web page
you know put some structure to it maybe
you have to break it out if you feel
like you have too much content there's
no harm in breaking it into part one
versus part two get people uh tease them
a bit get them to come back and read
part two okay use different content
forms in case somebody's interested
maybe you want to capture some data you
know prefer short paragraphs to make the
content readable remember if you're
talking to sea level folks you know
maybe you don't have to dummy down the
content so to speak but if you're
dealing with you know folks or people
that are right out of high school or
still in high school then adjust your
content and format and paragraphs
accordingly and then update the content
as well just because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done I mean when
we're talking about a web page we're
talking about something that is actively
changing or can change the medium that
is dynamic okay so if a data points
change go back in and update that data
point and then let people know about it
because they may want to come back and
and you know check in to see how much
that data points change so these are all
you know good takeaways for creating
high quality content you know some other
things that you should be aware of you
know grammatical mistakes you know you
need to avoid those there's no reason
for grammatical mistakes today's
technology doesn't allow for it and and
Hey listen we all have friends we have
colleagues my desk is sitting next to a
colleague who's more than happy to read
something before it gets published so
take advantage of the resources you have
available no reason for it because if
you have a grammatical mistake you just
lost a lot of credibility you know don't
be afraid to add a clear call to action
at the end of your content if somebody's
interested in reading it they're
probably going to be interested in
taking the next step whatever that next
step is okay so creating content that
fulfills viewers requirements meaning if
somebody's searching for something and
your content shows up in the search
results then they're actively looking
for you what are you offering them is it
fulfilling their requirements you know
don't be afraid to use examples
throughout your content in fact work in
or integrate some case studies in there
show clear examples to stress your
points
and then just don't put words on a web
page you know to break up that content
with an image that's going to be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help create visually appealing content
and then get more information to your
audience and we say prefer to give more
information meaning hey going back to
the content I was saying about breaking
it up organizing it if you have more
information you know don't withhold it
have them come back and read a secondary
blog post or secondary piece that
supports the original now we want to
move from high quality content to
running a B test maybe tests so
important why because with a B split
testing you can increase your conversion
rates okay so four elements to test in
your content marketing strategy so if
you have content say a Blog and you're
testing that blog you test out the
images shifts test out the forms do you
have a long form or short form you know
test out the content length you can have
a variation that is a lot shorter than
the original does that increase or
decrease bounce rates play around with
call to actions your call to actions do
matter you know do you want to use a
softer call to action a softer tone or
do you want to use something very direct
and strong you know test call to actions
to see what's going to get people to
move closer through the closer to
purchasing and through that funnel so a
b testing to me is something that should
be naturally done with Google optimize
it's free so with images you know you
could test a lot of different variations
of images anything from people to you
know outlandish image rates or just
something very stock and neutral but
just make sure that those images are
relevant to the post you know test the
length of that content you know again if
you know that your average time on page
is very low you know don't write
something very long write something that
you think is going to stick with that
time of page but on your A B test create
something maybe a little longer if it's
engaging enough maybe somebody's gonna
stay a little bit longer on the page so
you know create a variation is going to
play with that length Okay so use
analytics to your advantage to figure
out as a baseline what amount of content
is getting people to stay on the page
then see if you can push the envelope
one way or the other okay improving the
page with sign up forms really what you
want to do is create a user friendly
experience so when you have sign up
forms and don't make them non-intuitive
don't make them difficult you know link
maybe up to Facebook or Google so if
they're creating an account they can
create an account via Google or Facebook
or you know don't put too many forms on
the page and then on those ctas as I
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color I mean I
test color all the time believe it or
not color does matter don't use red use
green people react to different colors
but again you have cultural variances as
well so you got to take that into
account if you're in the Middle East or
the Far East Asia you know color schemes
and what you say matters and it changes
versus say you know Europe or the West
okay so keep that in mind when you're
making changes on color or tone or
placement and things of that nature so
you want to conduct a competitor
analysis so we're talking about creating
high quality content testing that
content you know brainstorming some
topics you know looking at your audience
you're doing all this work you might as
well take the next step and figure out
what it is your competitors are doing so
you can opt for competitive analysis by
identifying your competitors top
performing content for specific topics
okay and so really what we're trying to
do here is and improve our conversion
rates so what are your competitors doing
what are their baselines we can maybe up
that any I mean that data is also
available in Google analytics so you can
look at benchmarking reports in Google
analytics to get some form or fashion
you can also go to Facebook and look at
your competitors Facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of Engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using search
engines or check which websites are
competing with you and again that could
include Facebook as well or maybe even
LinkedIn so you go with the search
engine route you can always type in that
coveted keyword that you want to be
found for see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag in The Meta description you
can actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them recognized
in the search engine rankings so you can
certainly if you go to search engine
route you can certainly leverage an SEO
platform form like search sem rush or
Moz or something like that that's going
to allow you to get some good Insight on
competitor information so keep in mind
there are SEO platforms that will give
you information on your competitors and
that's what these SEO platforms are good
for so number five moving on choose a
suitable content format so now we've
done all this homework we know what we
want to say we know who we want to say
it to we're ready to do some testing but
we need to find a format because it's
not always about a web page per se
meaning content on a web page there's
not always about a blog post with
content in that blog post okay we need
to decide the type of content that's
going to fit what we're trying to say so
again you can go the traditional route
with just posting a blog post and
nothing wrong with that because with a
blog post you can incorporate video and
imagery you can also go more harder
route when I say harder more I say
official route with an e-book or case
study something that a user is going to
be able to take away with maybe download
something more official
um something more in-depth something
with a harder stamp on it so that that
shows individuals that you've taken the
time you've done this homework you've
done this research you've done some
really in-depth analysis and now the
proper format for that is not a blog
post it's an e-book now if you're into
talking like I am then you can certainly
do a podcast and podcasts are always
popular depending on the topic so you
got to be aware of the topic now videos
are always always a good option you got
the likes of video and video and YouTube
and some other you know video platforms
out there that allow you the ability to
get found very quickly especially with
the likes of YouTube you know people you
use YouTube before they go on to
purchasing a product so think about that
so if you're trying to get somebody if
you're trying to sway an audience to
move from being a brand awareness and a
loyal you know customer to taking the
next step okay to purchasing more or
purchasing for the first time and so
videos kind of help convey that now if
you're trying to convey a lot of
different points then an infographic
might be your best option instead of
having to write out all those points you
know try using an infographic to convey
those points visually now again with
blog posts it should have valuable
content that can be shared by your
website visitors on social so that's the
key make sure you have those shareable
social icons now with ebooks it should
have longer and in-depth content so and
it shouldn't be published frequently so
maybe if this is something you're doing
annually then ebook could be the format
with a case study what you should have a
customer story that succeeded and and
you solving that customer's problem so
the case study is always there for you
know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about infographic is just
visualizing data in a more organized way
in more visual way so somebody
understands what you're trying to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an interest in
Reading again it could be a certain age
certain gender a certain culture hey
everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is a podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience and
then videos are highly engaging they're
also shareable on blog posts and pretty
much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a Content management system
that's going to work for you so so you
want to be able to choose something
where you can plan appropriately produce
manage publish and measure results all
in one place there are plenty of content
Management Systems out there that will
help you do all of those things okay so
some examples are WordPress HubSpot
binder I mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging you know WordPress
is the way to go if you're into building
on landing pages that you want to you
know share you know HubSpot could be the
way to go okay there are lots of
available options out there so moving on
number seven Target your audience using
emails okay so what are we talking about
well we all know what emails are emails
help us to communicate directly with our
target audience and convert them to
leads so email is a good way to follow
up with your audience so if you've done
a podcast follow up with an email you
know maybe get them to to you know fill
out a survey via email based on that
podcast or if you create a podcast about
some data that you talked about in that
podcast follow up that with with them
via email with an infographic perhaps
okay built into the email okay there's
lots of ways that all these formats can
complement themselves via email okay you
could certainly take a blog post and
package it into an email and have a link
pointing back to the blog post maybe as
a teaser or if you're doing a series a
series of blog posts you know you could
tease that in an email so an email is a
good way to you know follow up with your
target audience indirectly or directly
when we say indirectly you know you can
collect emails and send out those emails
with you know certain information or
what you should be doing is targeting
and segmenting your emails just like you
are your content so if you're producing
content for a certain audience then May
make sure that particular audience gets
that same email now some of the email
content that you could share with your
target audience or newsletters okay
seasonal emails promotional emails
automated messaging and what we mean by
automated messaging hey if somebody just
purchased from you send them a thank you
email maybe follow up a couple days
later with another email with a survey
or what you could do is if you know who
your lawyer customers are you know
Target them with a promotional email so
there's lots of ways to slice and dice
content via email okay just make sure
you know your target audience is there's
lots of things you can do in email again
you can complement lots of different
formats within email as I mentioned
before with a podcast or a blog post so
keep all that in mind email is a good
way to communicate with your audience
okay the last point we want to make here
is use native ads okay so we talk about
Native ads it's one of the smartest ways
to connect your audience with your brand
so for example this is a native ad on
BuzzFeed okay it's about 15 bands that
probably wouldn't exist without Led
Zeppelin okay so for you folks out there
that don't know who Led Zeppelin is a
rock group from the 70s late 60s 70s
okay disbanded in 80 81 82 early 80s
okay but you know people grew up like
myself listening to Led Zeppelin okay so
you could see the headline here 15 bands
that probably won't exist with the
outlet Zeppelin you know I'm interested
in who those bands might be even if you
don't know who Led Zeppelin is okay you
might be inquisitive to say okay who is
this Led Zeppelin group and what are
these 15 bands the key here is not
necessarily the headline or Led Zeppelin
per se but it's a native ad and it's
sitting next to content talking about
music okay so according to Forbes online
audiences are 20 25 percent more likely
to look at a native ad than add a banner
and so that native ad in this case we're
talking about music needs to be sitting
or companyed alongside content talking
about in this case music you know would
help if it was rock music just music in
general might get enough to get Peak
people's interest okay so if you're
going to create content you know align
that content with something that's you
know naturally going to fit and that's
why we call them native ads because
they're native to the content that
they're associated with so finally after
all that said and done when all you've
done is create good content follow up
the emails targeting your audience and
associating that content with you know
content natively then you can always
measure your content performance so my
favorite part of it all you go into
analytics going to Facebook insights you
know you want to go in and check out how
that content is performing and you want
to do that because you want to be able
to see what's performing what's not
performing the key here is associating
the content with kpis that's really the
key so measuring the right metrics can
help you understand whether your content
is engaging or not so again measuring
the right metrics okay so when we're
talking about a video you're not
necessarily going to look at page views
you're going to look at video views so
you know some of these basic metrics of
users and sessions and Pages bounce rate
you know dwell time that's all great but
you just need to make sure that you're
aligning the right metric with the right
asset so for example if you have a case
study and ebook you want to make sure
that you're measuring how many downloads
the ebook or the case study received
again with the video you want to measure
video views now if your pack adding up
emails and sending them out to your
target audience you want to make sure
you look at open rates and click rates
okay so a lot of things you can be
looking at so make sure you choose the
right metrics because there's hundreds
and hundreds of metrics to choose from
so just be aware all the different
metrics that are available you know if
you're in it for search okay how much
traffic getting from search where are
you ranking so there are a lot of things
you need to think about so think about
the content that you're producing and
think about how you want to be able to
measure that content so let's go back
over our checklist here so what you
could do is create an editorial calendar
in fact I would highly suggest you
create an editorial calendar in order to
keep track of all the content you've
done over a period of time are you
making your content worth reading that
means are you checking the results of
that content what we just went over
measuring the content is it worth
reading have a column set up in that
editor our calendar you know performing
or not performing if it's not performing
don't do it again okay create your
content okay you always wanna you know
make sure you're reusing or using or
adding to the content that you've
created guest post on influential
blogger websites you want to add
statistics numbers and quotes to your
content make it engaging make it look
like you've done your homework you could
share all your content not just on
social media but you know platforms like
SlideShare now you can share it on all
social media platforms I'd highly
recommend it and again you can even
repurpose it as a blog post so if it's a
podcast then you know you can recite
that podcast in the form of a Blog okay
so get some testimonials that support
some of your content again create a
podcast you can send out an email with a
survey or trying to solicit some
testimonials or if you post something on
Facebook you know leverage the feed bag
you get from Facebook in the form of a
testimonial okay and then you want to
promote your blog post for maximum
success and a lot of that means SEO so
make sure you do your due diligence and
get the right keywords in that blog post
okay so you can create personas for
different user audiences okay so
remember it's all about tone okay so if
you're going to create a blog post make
sure your tone is aligned with that
Right audience whether that be young
middle aged or older are you choosing
the right type of content okay you'll
know based on the results okay you want
to add H1 and H2 tags on your web pages
why because when we're talking about
content we're talking about organizing
the content and H1 and H2S help you
organize the content appropriately
customize the metadata metadata is title
tag and meta tag descriptions and even
all tags okay all of that is for search
so you want your content to show up in
search whether that video infographic or
blog post all of it can be shown in
search results so make sure you write a
good title and make sure you write a
good meta description because that's
what people are going to see when they
search okay so you want to create a
detailed summary and title and again
that goes along with the title tag and
meta description and then you want to
make it easy for the audience to ask
questions and comment on your blog so
don't be afraid like I'm gonna do right
now in this video is if I'm missing
anything from this checklist feel free
to comment hey I've written my fair
share content but I could be talking to
an audience that is just as qualified as
I am and they may have some tips so feel
free to comment underneath this video
now don't be afraid to ask just like I
just did people are always willing to
provide constructive feedback so don't
be afraid to ask for it and make it easy
so to me every blog post needs to have
some form of a comment box because blog
posts are out there to solicit
engagement now let's recap everything we
talked about because we certainly
covered a lot and there's a lot to cover
when it comes to content marketing so
one know your audience again you can
lean on Google analytics you know
demographic data whether it be age or
gender you could do the same with
Facebook and Twitter and Linkedin you
know every platform has some data you
could take away create high quality
content when I mean high quality content
brainstorm some topics has it already
been written to death about or is this
unique you know don't write something
your competitors are writing okay don't
copy what your competitors have written
organize your content support it with
good imagery all of these are tips to
creating high quality content okay when
you create that content think about
running some a B test you know run some
variations and switch out the image
switch out the call to action see what's
going to get people to react and engage
with the content conduct competitor
analysis so lean on the Facebooks of the
world to see what your competitors are
posting see what's engaging for them
okay you can also lean on these SEO
platforms like sem rush and Moz all you
got to do is plug in a domain and
they're going to give you some
information about where particular
competitor ranks for keyword or how many
backlinks and what websites are linking
to them so all that's available in these
SEO platforms okay so you want to choose
a suitable content format we listed a
few from ebooks to case studies to
podcasts to infographics to blog posts
to videos it's up to you what you think
is best for your audience just keep in
mind you need to be able to measure it
and so that's the important thing if it
doesn't work the first time out then you
might want to consider changing out the
content format choose a Content
management system
um you know plenty out there WordPress
is a good one if you're going to be a
blogger okay blogging allows you to you
know post optimize that blog post you
know you could have the ability to share
that blog post across social platforms
and you can also have that blog post
show up in search engine results so you
can't do any of that without a good
content management system so you want to
Target your audience using emails okay
so email is a good way to again further
communicate with that particular
segmented audience and again you could
use it to send out promotional emails to
Loyal followers or you can use
systematic emails to send an email a
thank you email somebody purchased this
and then another follow-up email and
again you can repurpose some of the
content you've done in another format in
the form of an email so you know if you
created a video you know put that video
in the form of an email sent out to your
audience to make sure they're not
missing out on that video you just
created so lots of ways to use email
take advantage of email it's your ally
here okay use native ads okay don't be
afraid to put that content and hear it
with some other content on another
website it's been proven people are
going to engage in an ad that they see
based on the content they're currently
reading because the ad if it's native
it's going to be similar in nature to
the content they're currently engaged in
and then measure your content
performance I can't say this enough make
sure you're leveraging Google analytics
okay with Google analytics or Facebook
insights or Twitter or LinkedIn or any
other platform you're running on they're
gonna have data on what you've posted so
take advantage of it align your kpi so
if it's an ebook or case study don't
measure just traffic measure how many
people actually that downloading them
in most organizations the people who are
doing search engine optimization have
been doing it for a while
and I can tell you because I've been
doing it for a while that in the old
days
it was mostly technical with a little
bit of content sprinkled in so for
arguments like let's say 80 20. 80 of
what an SEO needed to learn how to do
had to deal with you know you know your
meta tags your metadata you know uh CMS
systems even blah blah blah blah blah
and oh by the way yeah you needed some
content on the pitch
well here we are a long time past that
and if this you you look through this
slide here for example this is the
latest guidance from Google
on the kind of content they want
and if you look through the list here
most of the items on it aren't technical
and frankly most of it is content and if
you think about it
what this means is is that the job
description for SEO has changed
dramatically
particularly beginning with the panda
update but then including the penguin
update and then hummingbird and pardon
me more and more and more seos had
better be interacting with the people
who are creating
quality content engaging content
credible content
um useful content it's not enough just
to put keywords in the right places
anymore on pretty thin content that
won't get you where you want to go
so again
different uh paths maybe the same
direction but the folks in content
marketing and the folks in SEO frankly
need each other and they may or may not
recognize it in your organization but
you know it's a starting point this is a
conversation you you probably need to
have
content marketing is complex
it often overlaps with other elements of
marketing the the most typical overlaps
are with social media marketing and SEO
and they're probably already are
in your organization those kind of
groups
the seos may be on
one floor and the social media marketing
people may be in a different building
you know whatever
but the new success formula it says we
got to get all those folks to the same
table
now we may have to do it virtually we
may have to use you know webinars in
order to hold those kind of meetings who
knows
but the point is is that uh you know the
world is Shifting and organizational
structures need to shift with it and
again you know that's not something you
can change tomorrow
but that is something that will evolve
over time and
for what it's worth it turns out that
let's just say uh the people who are in
SEO
they may or may not admit it at first
but they absolutely need to work with
the people in content marketing
why
because basically after Panda and
Penguin the rules shifted
and it's less about your title tag
and it's most mostly focused now on the
quality of your content
and whether that content is link worthy
which means it's really compelling
content it's remarkable content that's
content that's gonna get people to link
to it because wow that's
you know and that's not necessarily part
of the skill set that was required to be
a successful SEO five years ago or ten
years ago
so again you got to get these folks to
the table they've got to work together
you know and um and again that means the
organizational structure probably needs
to shift
and the same is true with the social
media marketing folks
you know they went out and their initial
goals and objectives were you know get
lots of likes you know get lots of fans
get lots of views skip lots of Twitter
followers why because that seemed to be
the metric that the platform gave us
and so we used it to measure success
well it turns out none of those measures
actually measure real success
because they're focused on being
successful on the platform
boy I have lots of fans as opposed to
being successful in business wow that
generated lots of leads and sales
so there is a real real discrepancy
between let's just say the center of
gravity
okay it's not Facebook you're not going
to make a lot of money on Facebook
you know that's just not set up to do
business
you've got to get those folks that
you've engaged in Facebook to your
website where they can buy something
and that's a you know radical shift for
all the folks who are in social media
marketing to say wait wait time out
but that's not what I was told a couple
years ago and the answer is that's
correct what we've learned over time is
that being engaging is useful
if it's harnessed to a benefit and I'll
tell you in most organizations the
social media marketing people are under
a cloud
because they aren't delivering business
benefit
and they too need to learn to work with
the content marketing people
in order to do that and in some cases
they may not be creating the right kind
of content
that actually generates leads and sales
as opposed to
you know is inexpensive to create to get
my next fan or my next Twitter follower
so the key metrics here are no longer
how many likes or comments or shares did
you get that's nice
but
how many sales leads did you generate
what percentage of those converted into
sales
that's a radical change
but again it helps when the social media
marketing people are at the table with
the content marketing people
thanks
greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
from Simply learn and today we're going
to talk about how to rank number one on
Google high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability to get your website ranked
number one on Google so let's just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on you know page four
of Google and it's that blog with ice
cream recipes and if it's just content
for the sake of content is not really
informative then it's not necessarily
going to get good engagement in the eyes
of Google you know they want to rank
content that's very informative it's
very fresh it's exciting to read it's
interesting it's going to have good
engagement so if it's a recipe or an
article about any topic if it's the
content is just non-informative then
you're not going to get good engagement
and when you don't get good engagement
of people don't stay on the site to
engage in the content and they just
leave the website after landing on the
page causing a bounce then the content
is just going to continue to fall down
the rankings and we want to prevent that
we want to move up the rankings we want
to be number one on Google we don't
necessarily want to fall in the rankings
for our content so content is a key
driver in being able to rank number one
on Google so if the content is on page
nine what can we do well we want to be
able to you know take that content and
do something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like Facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that Community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summertime time and you're
engaging with your community on that
platform then the likelihood of that
community on that platform is going to
increase engagement increased engagement
will send social signals to the search
engine it says hey this content is good
quality likewise for any other platform
most social media platforms have
engagement metrics and those engagement
metrics pass signals is it good is it
not good do we like this content are we
giving it a thumbs up are we going to
want to follow it are we going to want
to share it and so if you share content
that you feel is engaging on social
platforms then it's going to be engaging
and it's likely going to cause an
increase in engagement for example a
decrease in balances and once you share
that quality content then the likelihood
of it moving up the rankings even as far
as number one on Google is going to be
greater so you always want to start out
writing good quality content so let's
talk about good quality content because
Google does take content seriously they
do take into account what other people
think of that content so high quality
content is an important factor so how to
create good content that's always the
question so let's talk about some best
practices here remember in the last
segment we talked about keyword research
so we want to perform good keyword
research why because we want to choose
keywords remember we're choosing
multiple keywords per page one key word
could be related to our brand one
keyword could be related to the content
but another keyword could be related to
a user's intent like recipes if you
recall the example we use with bread
recipes maybe somebody's looking to type
in a keyword that says how do I make you
know a bread or how do I make a specific
type of bread or how do I make banana
bread or what's the best recipe for
banana bread they're question related
and we want to be able to answer those
questions so that's where choosing those
right keywords that's going to respond
to a user's intent so starts with
choosing the right keywords so remember
we talked about a number of different
tools when we talk about keyword
research so there's a research tool that
you can use called phrase.io and that
will help you do quick research on you
know keywords and Trends and whatnot so
if you know a better research tool that
you use for keyword research then drop
us a comment below I'd be interested in
getting your comments about keyword
research and what research tools are out
there so if you know something better
than phrase.io drop a comment below and
we'd be interested in getting your
perspective so keyword research is key
but creating content that fulfills users
requirements so answering those
questions it's a recipe we want to
answer that question if it's directions
we want to answer that question question
if they don't know how to do something
we want to answer that question and
that's the whole idea behind content
content is not just to fill a page it's
to really fulfill users requirements
that's when you get good engagement so
if somebody's typing in something on
Google and they're looking for an answer
your content should answer that question
but we also want to make the content
readable so in other words you know
write for your audience don't impress
anybody with very high vocabulary type
words that somebody doesn't necessarily
know the meaning of don't use jargon
don't use a street language for example
use everyday common language that's just
easily digestible when your audience is
reading and then we want to keep that
content organized and so when we mean
organized we want to use headers and
subheaders you know break your content
into paragraphs keep the flow organized
if we can keep the flow organized then
it's going to be easier for somebody to
read and then it's okay to add resources
especially resources from credible sites
so if you can incorporate those
resources in there then it's just going
to add The credibility to your content
let the audience know that hey I've done
my research on this topic and this is
what this person has to say about it
this person who seems to be credible
okay so it only adds value to your
content so these are all tips to
Remember When creating content and then
the one important tip here is we want to
use white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say opt for
white hack techniques that's what we
mean write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so there are
different types of content so there's
content where you you just write words
to install text based you could also use
an infographic infographic is simply
just a graphic that visualizes exactly
what you're trying to explain for
example if we want to write an article
about how to write good engaging content
we don't necessarily have to write all
that out as a text we can create an
infographic so for example here's an
infographic on 20 effective ways to
basically not bore your readers but
write engaging content so you could see
this is an infographic it's all
graphically laid out so infographics
tend to be easier to understand because
they're visual they're easy for the end
user to comprehend because there's
generally no jargon it's usually images
that are portraying the points of what
you're trying to get across and so it
tends to break it up the monotony of
just text it's more visually appealing
and it's laid out and organized so you
can see this infographic has 20
different steps or rules and they lay
those out all here in this infographic
and the great thing I like about
infographics is you could you could
share them on social media you can
re-engage them as a post you can save
them from really any social platform so
infographics tend to tell a better story
and versus say just writing text you can
use video and images so you don't
necessarily have to lay it all out in an
infographic you can certainly insert a
video or an image into your content
especially if it's a blog post if it's a
blog post then sometimes video and
images on its own tell the story you
don't necessarily need text to go ahead
and tell your story a video or an image
as they say tells a thousand words and
so images and videos are great to use in
a blog post so using different forms of
content you know you always want to
review your content when a user dwells
on your web page for a longer time
Google will tend to think okay this
person's engaged so we're going to rank
that favorable so if you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
HubSpot so the more word count you use
the more words you use the chances of
you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessary just words it's the words and
how those words are written how they're
structured the types of keywords you're
using how you're engaging with your
audience there's a lot of factors again
there's best practices we just went over
but the key is you know if you have
longer more engaging content then it's
going to bode better for you on search
engines so a couple of steps to create
high quality content so you want to
begin with a comprehensive introduction
so always introduce your content
remember the content should be relevant
to the keyword so if you're choosing
keywords and your keyword research think
about answering that question if
somebody's typing in bread recipes maybe
they're looking for banana bread recipes
how to make the best banana bread or how
to make banana bread using dried figs we
want to be able to align our content
with that keyword naturally you want to
create a title that's worthy that's
click worthy so remember if you're in
Google Google search and you're doing
search for something simple like bread
recipes we want to make something that's
going to be you know engaging for
somebody to click on like easy perfect
yeast spread or easy crusty French bread
or something that's going to be engaging
you know the best bread recipes or how
to make the best homemade bread you know
something that's going to draw
somebody's attention to the title of
that blog post so we want to include LSI
keywords so what I mean by LSI keywords
in your content we mean you know long
tail keywords make it natural headings
and subheadings should consist of
keywords and variants so if you're
writing headers and subheaders include
the keyword in there and that way the
content always stays relevant to the
audience okay shorten your sentences in
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easy for the
end user to read and we want to always
put internal links on our blog post why
because if we have internal links then
if we have a link from one blog post to
another blog post or say our blog post
to an internal page on our website we
want to make sure that it's relevant
content that way somebody's reading
something and you have an internal link
let's just say from a bread recipes page
to a banana bread recipes page then they
may find it interesting click on that
link and go to the banana bread recipes
page so it's keeping somebody engaged on
your website so putting in internal
linking will help keep the end user
engaged because you're offering up links
that's relevant to the content you
always want to break up that content
with images okay we want to use alt tags
meaning we want to pen the image with
text so that way if the image doesn't
load then at least the alt text will
load so we can incorporate call out
boxes and more importantly we want to
update our content regularly so we
always want to get the best recipe out
there if it's banana bread or different
ways to Crepe banana bread or always
just coming up with ways to update the
content so we want to keep our content
our blog post fresh and then we want to
include a CTA call to action if we
include a call to action then that's
going to keep somebody engaged and have
them act on your content so these are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here and
this is a three-month-old post on
BuzzFeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
on a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012. again a lot of
Engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we could see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because listen you know it's engaging
content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging and it includes sources from
high Authority websites some do's and
don'ts on the content so take into
account the best practices I mentioned
about creating high quality content okay
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content I.E in the form of infographics
Graphics or videos or text or images you
can add images from public domain sites
you can be relatable and use examples to
clarify points just like the BuzzFeed
article simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some Do's the don'ts obviously
don't lift content we don't want to lift
content from another website so that's
plagiarism so we want to have our own
unique content we also don't want to
take images from other websites and so
if you do happen to find an image that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website ideally that's not a good
situation but if you do happen to do
that then always give credit to the
website okay so if you took it from
xyz.com credit xyz.com for the image and
even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take images from other
websites just as much as you don't want
to take copy you don't want to take
images use your own imagery and content
but if you don't have imagery then you
can always go to stock photography there
are plenty of websites out there where
you can sign up for a subscription like
Adobe stock images as an example you can
sign up for an account and in some cases
you can sign up for a free account and
use stock imagery okay don't give less
information to your audience give them
to your audience what they deserve which
is the information they're looking for
they're looking for the best banana
bread recipes give them the best banana
bread recipes incorporate your own
images break it up with titles give them
a good quality piece of content that
they're going to be able to engage with
and so if you put long paragraphs in
your content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long pair
paragraphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content creating high quality videos and
some of the best practices around that
so along with everything we mentioned
about choosing the right keywords we
always need to keep in mind that the
videos we create need to be of high
quality so the content itself in
addition to the keywords is a primary
factor in ranking so in order to have
keywords we need to have content and in
order to rank we need to have you know
good content so let's talk a little bit
about creating content and what's
involved with that and what we really
mean by high quality videos so if you
have a video content that is not
informative or irrelevant to the topic
it won't rank so that's just common
sense so you need to create content
that's aligned with the topic obviously
and then that way you have keywords that
are aligned with the content so but if
you have content it really isn't aligned
with the topic then you're not going to
rank no matter how much you've optimized
that video so just keep that in mind so
there's a couple of things we want to
look at here so high quality content is
determined by really two metrics so
we're not sure about how good our
content is and how good of a high
quality video we created we want to look
at audience retention and user
engagement so audience retention when
simply the percentage length of your
video that the audience has watched It's
the percentage your audience has watched
so focusing on audience retention is
important for people who want their
videos to rank high so if you want to
rank you need to optimize for the
keywords but got to keep in mind content
so content is related to audience
retention and user engagement so
audience tension percentage length your
video of your video that the audience
has watched and for example it can be
both absolute in minutes or percentages
so audience retention can be the average
view duration or percentage of the
audience that watched then we have user
engagement so yours engagement of
viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
Engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so what do
we mean behind longer videos so what's
the reason for longer videos let's just
suppose we have two videos one shorter
in length and one longer in length first
video is 15 minutes long the second
video was seven minutes long so on
average if viewers watch about 40 of
both videos then video x which is 15
minutes long will have more than twice
the watch time of the video that's seven
minutes long so remember duration we
want you know people to watch our videos
longer so if the video is longer in
length if it's 40 then it's gonna have a
longer audience engagement audience
retention so that's one of the reasons
you know from a metric standpoint so
even when viewers watch you know both
videos the time is going to differ so we
want to take into account longer videos
for primarily that reason is because you
know it gives an end user an opportunity
to watch the video longer and then it's
going to help us rank our videos longer
so when we talk about watch time so if
one video has higher watch time than the
other watch time is just the number of
views times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to keep the content
organized my recommendation is you know
create an outline first and once you
create an outline of how the video is
going to flow then start populating with
content and so to me that's how you can
keep the flow organized okay is really
with an outline starting out with an
impound there's no videos are no
different than say a presentation if
you've done a PowerPoint presentation
you always want to start out doing an
outline then we want to upload a high
resolution videos high resolution we
don't want to create videos that you
know are small resolution like say you
know 400 by 400 resolution or something
you know something really small we want
to create something a very high res so
according to back or link Oaks more than
50 of videos on the first page of
YouTube are high definition so high
definition videos of higher quality are
going to be shown on the first page of
each more often than not so high
resolution videos organizing the content
publishing longer videos are examples of
creating high quality video we also want
to make sure that content is relevant to
the title so if we're talking about
machine learning Basics you know
obviously the content is going to be
about you know intro to machine learning
or what is machine learning and then the
title should reflect that content so
aligning the title sets the expectation
for the end user so when they see a
title what is machine learning then when
they watch the video they're expecting
to learn about machine learning and what
it is so if it meets expectations then
the chances are that person who's
watching the video is going to watch it
longer and that means it's going to
fulfill the viewers requirements and
when you align everything accordingly
keywords titles content then at the end
of the day the user is going to watch it
and the more they watch it the higher
the engagement the higher the engagement
the better chance you have to rank some
other tips that you could use to create
high quality videos so we want to be
able to you know use examples to clarify
our content so you know don't be afraid
to go into another screen like I am if I
want to I'm talking about videos jump
into the machine learning Basics video
which I've done throughout this session
I can simply do that by keeping the user
engaged here this video is about machine
learning Basics well the titles online
with the video we made sure that we have
a nice description about what the video
is about and we're aligning the
expectations so not only that I'm
showing you example within the video
itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or example in the video and then
when we talk about imagery you know you
want to use good images in your video so
I use public domain sites that are
available to you like shutter stock or
flat icon I mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to use high
quality images in your video give more
information to your audience okay giving
maximum relevant information can help
gain more views and so when we talk
about more information again it goes
back to you know the examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create original content so always
create original content you could
certainly get ideas from YouTube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on YouTube itself but
you know when you're going to create a
video yeah you can create another video
about what is machine learning but just
make sure it has your own take on it
you're the subject matter expert when
creating the video create it with your
own original content have high audio
quality and video effects so just like
you see here on this video we have
effects in it and the audio is of high
quality meaning no background noise no
Distortion and we want to be able to
speak clearly in the video so you want
to speak clearly loudly concise just as
I'm trying to do now so that you can
understand what I'm trying to say or
what the viewer is trying to to
understand when they're watching the
video so watching and listening are two
of the components and you want to make
sure both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
Point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content
that's aligned with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content that go along with the video
that outline I referenced earlier in
terms of organization you always want to
have a Content outline so what topics
are you going to cover in the video
that's why you need the outline to point
that out confirm that before you
actually start creating the video okay
focus on the initial 15 seconds so
that's key you know somebody's going to
click the play button of your video and
if you don't catch them in the first 15
seconds then they're likely going to
pause the video or just go ahead and
close it out altogether so you want to
be able to capture somebody's attention
right off the bat and even before they
click on that play button you want to
make sure again you're exceeding
expertise Nations that title is aligned
with the content so in your first 15
seconds it basically needs to be catchy
but also setting the expectation of what
the user is expecting so in this example
here we want to pay close attention to
the first 15 seconds that's when viewers
are most likely to drop off so we can
look at audience retention in YouTube so
use the options above the graph to view
absolute audience retention or relative
audience retention so audience retention
is basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning Basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example I can say you know
43 44 watch the video for at least two
minutes here I can see
28.6 Watership for six minutes plus so
that
so that's retention it gives us an idea
in terms of percentage how many people
or percentage of people watch the video
at what length so that's audience
retention so we want to keep that number
high at the very initial stage of the
video and we want to keep it high
throughout and that's why you always
want to create high quality content
using those examples using imagery
making it organized content not pausing
you know going from one point to the
other those are all best practices to
keep the viewer engaged and then we want
to add resources from well-known sites
so throughout this video we've used
backlinko there are other sources we've
used so if you have a source go ahead
and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning Basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or you two can recommend to the audience
to set up ends screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by Auto playing the
next video so if you enable this feature
it's going to go from one video to
another pattern interrupts keep the
audience engaged so basically it allows
for your audience to stay within one
video without having any interruptions
involved and so going back to the did
you know audience retention report helps
you analyze how well your videos are
engaging to the audience so what do we
mean by that well if I go back again to
my audience retention report how
engaging was it well I could see 42
percent 43 percent watched it on average
of 3 minutes and 21 seconds so to me
that's pretty good of course we always
want 100 of the video the video is seven
minutes long if almost half of our
audience saw over half of the video then
I would say that's pretty good people
were engaged so audience retention just
is a good report to start looking at to
help you understand how engaging is my
video and if your video is not engaging
you know you can always go back and edit
it or fix it or tweak it so remember the
average view duration for all videos and
top performing videos listed by all time
we can look at that information as well
in addition we can look at demographics
so we can get an overview of the age
gender and location and we can look at
playback locations report and what the
playback locations report does is it
helps us determine the platforms where
our videos are being streamed from
within YouTube look at the traffic
sources where did the viewers come from
devices did they look on mobile or
tablet and so if there's any doubts you
know if you have any questions please
drop a comment below but especially if
you have any doubts on the metrics so if
we go back into YouTube we can look at
analytics and if we're looking at
analytics we can see more and then this
is going to show us everything we need
to see from device type so if I click on
more I can see my playback location so
this will show me where the video is
watched it was on a watch page or a
channel page I could see the traffic
sources I could see the gender and age
so if I click on the viewer age report I
can see the percentage of views by age
so I can get a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they need to know okay so
it's all within YouTube analytics so
again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to YouTube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to YouTube
high quality alignment your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at YouTube Analytics
now before
take a refresher on what exactly is
content marketing
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves the creation and sharing
of online content to help generate
audience interest in a Brand's product
or services this means providing
information that the audience considers
valuable and relevant in a consistent
manner so that it drives some sort of
profitable customer action
so let's talk about the content that
falls under content marketing there's
options like blogs videos
infographics case studies white papers
and ebooks
so why is content marketing so important
firstly it helps build awareness trust
and loyalty in your brand
the more your brand provides accurate
and well-researched content the more
people learn about and trust your brand
the more the audience trusts the new the
more they're likely to buy from you
creating the content is relatively
inexpensive and can be done in-house
content marketing will also enable your
brand to increase traffic to your site
and get more conversions
it also helps improve other marketing
tactics like search engine optimization
social media and public relations
now let's have a look at the content
marketing process
the first step is to determine what
goals you want to achieve with your
marketing campaign it could be increased
conversions website signups and so on
then you set up buyer personas from
among your audience that can buy your
content
but what exactly are buyer personas now
these are research-based profiles that
represent your Target customer via
personas help you describe your Brand's
ideal audience
the decisions they make the challenges
they face their interests and so on
next you'll have to set up content
audits to determine the best type of
content that works for you you also need
to set up a Content management system
like HubSpot Squarespace Wix and
WordPress they'll help you with
increased collaboration greater support
run a B test and much more
you need to brainstorm for new forms of
content that your audience can enjoy
after that you can zero in on a
particular form of content that would
work the best for you and finally you
can publish and manage your content now
let's talk about content marketing tips
number one remarket your content content
marketing is one of the many ways you
can spread your content to a wider
audience you can Define the audience you
want to Market to and then tag visitors
who come to your site and using Google's
Display Network you can strategically
position your ads in front of people on
Google or its partner websites who
previously interacted with your website
and advertise to them
through this you can build awareness and
engagement with your audience
here's an example of a banner
advertisement I would be shown if I was
shopping for a MacBook Pro on Amazon and
change my mind at the last moment
this ad would maybe stay at the back of
my head until eventually I go and finish
that purchase
now let's go to number two answering
complex questions with your content
targeting specific keywords is extremely
helpful with your content this is why
you need to focus on Google's featured
snippet disposition also known as
position 0 enhances and draws user
attention on the search engines result
page
through the featured snippet you can
drive a large amount of traffic to your
website while cementing your position as
an expert in your industry you can have
different forms of Snippets like
definition boxes where a snippet of text
gives researchers direct and concise
definitions and descriptions you could
have tables where data is taken from the
page and displayed in a table you could
have ordered lists where items are
presented in specific order and you can
also have unordered lists
next up number three we have create a
personality for your brand if you're
looking to grow a following for your
content try not to copy how already
established and successful corporate
blogs do things
nowadays audiences tend to prefer
content that has a certain humanness
about it
tend to follow solo influencers they
advertise their brand by being
themselves
in a way they're selling themselves by
being themselves
you need to analyze what is popular and
influential blogs are doing and
incorporate into your Brand's website
thanks to this your audience will
connect with you and come back for more
now here's an example of one of the
largest players in digital marketing
Neil Patel see how he himself is the
brand and if you've gone through his
content you know it's pretty great as
well
that's what you should be striving for
moving on to tip number four ensure that
your content matches your Brand's voice
to make sure of this you need to
constantly review your editorial
standards and make sure your tone and
quality remain consistent you need to
ask your audience questions about how
you can develop and refine your Brand's
voice
by answering these questions you can
provide your audience with a more
cohesive and helpful experience your
tone of your brand can vary on the basis
of what type of content you are planning
to post and what the goal you want to
achieve from the campaign next up we
have number five back up your Arguments
for data
using statistics and facts to make a
point by including a link to the
original Source makes it extremely
credible this data can help the audience
grow trust in your brand to persuade
them that your content is valid and
valuable this will also help your brand
grow as an industry expert
at number six we have use specific
keywords now make sure you use specific
keywords in your content this takes care
of the SEO aspect behind your content
this will also help your content have a
greater chance of being found indexed
and ranked
it could also help your content rank for
Niche topics within your industry moving
on to tip number seven evaluate the
success of your content with data
earlier we talked about why it's so
important that you backup your content
with data now let's talk about how data
can help you improve
analytics tools will help you learn more
about how well your content is doing the
age demographics of the people enjoying
it who doesn't their locations the best
time to post and much more with this
data you can make sure that your time
and money are being used in the best
possible way
some of the most popular tools in the
market are bussumo Evernote HubSpot
Trello and WordPress
these will help you find topics and
influencers within your industry you can
capture organize and share notes
collaborate with team members create
sales funnels and much more
now we've reached Midway right now so
I've got a question for you
do you guys have any tips for Content
marketing that we haven't covered yet
let me know in the live chat
alright so let's get back to our list
tip number eight is to be consistent
with your content
post your best performing content and
make sure they follow a consistent
schedule
finding a balance of the different types
of content to be posted with the help of
a Content calendar will show your
audience that you're committed to
providing them helpful and informative
content
this will also establish your brand as
an authority and thought leader within
your Niche it will help your audience
depend on you for quality content and
give them a reason to return tip number
nine is to make your content actionable
providing actionable steps or
information in your content will coerce
your audience to take a particular
action quickly it can help you create
valuable content and fix pain points
faced by your audience build a strong
relationship with them and earn their
trust it also leads to increased
engagement and a positive brand
experience
it provides users with real value and
solutions leading them to take action
here we have an example from Trello
where we see a pop-up with a call to
action asking interested users to input
their email IDs to sign media today
involving more than 200 marketers more
than 49 percent of them felt content
marketing was really important to their
digital marketing campaigns and more
than 25 percent of their budgets are
used for visual advertising content like
images infographics videos and other
forms of rich media will help you
enhance the message of your brand and
reach a wider audience
here's an example of advertising by
Coca-Cola
although there's not a lot of text in
the ads you can immediately recognize
the unmistakable branding and the
message they're trying to send moving on
to tip number 11
create trending and Evergreen content
creating content that's Evergreen and
trending with your own unique angle
statistics and research will be a huge
advantage since you'll have to update it
every now and then you'll get a great
deal out of the work without having to
do a lot of work
here's an example of one such Evergreen
article people are never going to stop
wanting to learn how to do SEO so with a
little tweaking every few months to
reflect new changes that Google may have
done you'll have an article that you can
get considerable mileage out of next up
tip number 12 is to understand content
that works for you
you need to analyze what content works
on different social media platforms for
example you all know YouTube is the best
place for video content Instagram and
Pinterest for visual content Twitter for
smaller Snappy content and so on
understanding what works and what
doesn't will help you better spread your
content across the internet
tip number 13 is to understand your
target audience
now like I mentioned earlier your
marketing campaign isn't going to bear
fruit without targeting a specific
audience
understanding who your audience is is
one of the most important steps for this
you can find this out by asking
questions like who you're engaging with
online their age location language Etc
by using social listening to find out
what audiences are talking about your
brand using tools to research what
social channels your audience is using
and so on
after understanding them you can set up
buyer personas for your audience
tip number 14 is to perform a b testing
now ab's testing will help you
understand what your audience likes or
doesn't what content works for you and
much more you can do a b testing on
headlines and title tags call to actions
content formats image types content
length and much more it can also help
you make better decisions in the future
and finally our tip number 15 is to
reach out to people sharing similar
content
one of the best ways to build your
audience is to get people or influencers
who already shared content within your
Niche to share your content
now since these people already have a
trusting audience they would be a lot
more likely to enjoy your content
content marketing interview questions
and answers so thanks for joining again
and here's how it's gonna work so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
you as soon as possible we're going to
go through a series of questions and I'm
going to answer those questions for you
starting out what are the essential
components of a good web content okay so
essential components okay so what do we
want our content to do well we want it
to be useful so web content should be
written in a way which caters to what
the reader wants okay so somebody's not
going to read your content if it's not
useful for them okay this because it
affects reader engagement okay so if
it's not interesting it's not useful
somebody's just not going to read it
plain and simple it also has to be
engaging so listen even if it is
relevant to a user you still have to
write the content so it's engaging so
you want to add elements like imagery
videos hey you can even turn your
content into an infographic okay you
want to do something that's going to be
engaging for the user if it's engaging
they're going to read it and engage with
the content okay and then good content
should have some call to action so
content must be written in a way that
can drive call to action okay so if
you're writing a blog post you know I've
seen a lot of blog posts just simply
start and with good content but it
doesn't leave the user with anywhere to
go so have that call to action put some
internal links in that content give
somebody a place to go after they're
done engaging with the good content you
write okay so some other things to think
about some other components for good
content well credibility so you know
anybody can write what are you writing
about something you know what you're
writing about are you a good talking
point a good expert or have experience
about this content so you also want to
use you know if information from a
legitimate Source okay so you don't want
to grab something in your and use it in
your content that's just not legitimate
because it does hurt your credibility
and the organization's credibility and
then also originality I mean write
something that nobody else has written
so obviously you don't want to
plagiarize because if you plagiarize and
there are tools out there where people
can easily just put their content in
there to see what else is out there see
if somebody else has plagiarized it so
it's very easy to find people who
plagiarize so don't be that person what
I would recommend create a good content
calendar and come up with some ideas
before you write them next question
related to content marketing so what are
the types of content you can create well
there are a lot of things you can create
start with the blog blog to me is always
a great place to start it's a blank
canvas for your ideas your thoughts your
opinions okay that's a great thing about
a Blog it it accentuates personality you
can create a video videos are always
engaging you can create an infographic
infographics to me are you know Hidden
Gem instead of somebody reading the same
old same old you're laying this out in a
very visual way that's easy to
understand create a case study okay so
if you're you know digital marketing
expert you know done social media for
another client you know write about it
you know show the successes show that
you are an expert show that you've
created successful campaigns and social
and in the form of case study you can
create a white paper white papers are a
good educational pieces you can also
create an ebook Okay ebook hey if you
have a lot of content you want to lay it
out and ebook's a good way to go and you
have a lot of choices here when it comes
to content a lot of choices okay so what
are the advantages of having a Content
calendar so I alluded to that just a
couple of seconds ago so let's really
break this down here because content
calendars to me are so important well
first of all counterpart of content
count there allows you to think about
dates so if you're planning something
you're going to have important dates in
mind okay so content calendar it almost
ensures you don't miss anything you know
that's a good opportunity for you to
leverage like you know Black Friday
Cyber Monday you know it's probably
important you know when those days are
if you're in e-commerce so that's why
having a Content calendar helps it helps
you plan out your content based on
important dates or based on dates that
work for what you're trying to do they
also help because you could stick to a
consistent schedule okay so if you don't
have a Content calendar you're probably
just arbitrarily writing content here
and there well what if your users crave
and really engage with the content
they're going to want more sticking to
something consistent is going to really
get people to come back for more they
know when you're going to post they're
going to be waiting for it and if it's
every Tuesday morning 8 o'clock hey post
it Tuesday morning 8 o'clock your users
will get used to that schedule and and
it does help build up your following it
does help help build up your community
and in the end cultivates a long lasting
relationship and having a Content
calendar also allows you to mix up your
content okay so you can see and plan
ahead different types of content in
different formats that way it allows you
to mix it up okay whether it be a blog
post uh an infographic a video about
different topics okay some other
advantages here saving time it just
allows you to prepare for the future
when you can prepare you're efficient
and when you're efficient you're not
wasting time and so to me having a
Content calendar is a must because a lot
of us are busy who has time and
especially if you're going to work in a
new company let's say writing content
you definitely want to have a Content
counter because you're going to want to
use that time to efficiently plan this
is a new company you're going to start
working at you want to understand who
this company is is what they've done in
the past what you haven't done and what
you want to do okay so all of that helps
you plan and prepare and it saves you
the time and effort and hassle down the
road and then at the end of the day you
want to be able to figure out what works
so planning your posts puts less strain
on you and your team members as well as
company resources because when you plan
and you post you're going to get data
and then when you get data it's either
going to work or not work and if it
doesn't work then you know in the future
you're not going to put that piece of
content or that topic in the content
calendar again it's that simple okay
some other advantages fresh content okay
so having a con content calendar allows
you to always keep content fresh again
you're going to be on a consistent
schedule and you're not going to be
writing about the same things over and
over again so it could be just simply
Twitter if you're putting a Content
calendar and together for Twitter well
you don't want to have the same tweets
every other day so it does ensure that
you're getting tweets out there that are
fresh that are new that are different
and again figure out what works a
Content counter makes it easier to
measure results and optimize performance
so you always want to you know maybe put
some metrics in with your content
calendar so you can see side by side
content historically that is performed
content that is not performed okay so
next question you may get what type of
content Works in each stage of the
customer life cycle so you have
awareness engagement purchase post
purchase advocacy okay so let's break
these down here so awareness okay so you
want people to understand who you are
okay that could be a guest blog an
influencer helping you out it could be a
cold email a video that can potentially
go viral a social media post introducing
a product you have engagement so you
want people to engage with your content
what are you going to do to get people
to engage well you could certainly write
an email and have people open that email
and go to your website you can have an
ebook where people can actually download
and read it or you can have a Blog where
people can comment or landing page where
they can fill out a form submission you
have a valuation so with social media we
know there's a lot of Engagement going
on but when you're putting content out
there you can certainly open it up to
testimonials okay you can generate white
papers okay or you can generate case
studies case study is a good way for
companies to evaluate what you've done
in the past if you've worked in it for a
specific product in the past and it's
worked you certainly want to put that
out there for potential clients in that
same industry purchase trying to get
people to purchase what are you going to
do well you can certainly have landing
pages a nice you know website a nice
shopping cart with some nice content
okay onboarding emails get those emails
out there and get people to go back to
the website and purchase of course you
can have product and service details as
well meaning you know one one page
downloadable PDFs that describe the
product okay a post purchase okay so
people who've already purchased you
could certainly send out follow-up
emails and you can do blog roundups you
know give people an opportunity to see
what features or updates are happening
to the product okay of course case
studies of repeat customers or content
types that detail a new feature or
service okay so if somebody's already
purchased hey you may want to send them
some content of another product that
complements the product they bought so a
lot of things you can do to engage with
your user who's already purchased and
then advocacy you want people to help
you out here so have the user generate
the content you can have exclusive
discounts for your community they're
going to be your Advocates so give them
exclusive discounts and then pictures of
customers engaging with your products
okay who's not going to share that so
you're going to have people share that
information in other words you can
generate content where hey people can
help you out here and be your advocate
okay so how do you decide what topic and
subject to write on okay well going back
to the content counter that always
counts you could see what you put in
that content calendar but there are some
other methods you can use and you could
certainly identify your target audience
and not only identify your target
audience but what their needs are okay
so you can write content based on
audience you could certainly do some
research with keywords okay what's
trending what keywords are not trending
okay and right around what's trending
for example okay you could certainly
take a look at social media for example
quora I always look at quora Cora's
interesting entertaining informational
hey people are certainly having
conversations on Quorum and you can
certainly analyze those conversations
because they certainly get in depth and
you can decide hey do I want to write a
topic around something that really just
won't go away in terms of conversing
core is a good example of analyzing
conversations they tend to be a little
bit more in depth so some other things
you could do you can look at your
competitors and what kind of
conversations are happening on your
competitors blogs or your competitors
social media platforms and Pages you can
keep track of blogs and articles from
subject matter experts commentators
critics and so on okay so you can get
ideas from them another question you may
get which is very important if you're
going to start working for a company you
need to understand the tone the tone of
your content because that is going to
fit and be in line with the company
you're working for okay so you're always
going to have a brand personality so the
characteristics of a brand are the
guidelines based on which the content
strategy is developed the tone of the
content must align itself to the content
strategy your audience profile so you
got you need to determine who your
audience is okay and how the brand wants
to be seen by that audience so you know
if you have an older audience you're not
going to use younger audience I.E street
lingo or today's lingo and and the
younger generation you're going to use
you know language that's going to fit
the audience you're talking to and then
of course the channel itself so the
content you create must be irrespective
of the channel and consistent with brand
attributes okay so you gotta pick and
choose the channel if it's LinkedIn for
example hey you know linkedin's more
business oriented okay so you're not
going to be you know as humorous as you
would be say on Instagram or Facebook
all of these have one thing in common
again that's brand guidelines you have
to stay within the brand what is the
Brand's personality how do we want to
talk to our audience and what platform
are we using to talk to our audience how
do you promote your content once it's
live well that's always a good question
hey you doing the the work the putting
in the hard work to create this you know
it could be a video and videos take a
long time it could be an infographic an
e-book okay so send it out via email
okay if you haven't an email list send
it out and let people know this
content's there put a link in the email
or or even a piece or snippet or preview
of the content in the email so you're
using the email to broadcast and
encourage people to you know if it's an
ebook get the rest of the ebook Okay you
can certainly leverage social media to
engage with your community that's the
best you know just as good as email get
out there and let people know hey I got
I got my book published come and
download it you know you can give a
discount to the first 100 people that
download it okay you can always promote
your content via ads so whether that be
Google or Facebook you always have an
opportunity to meet more prominent
social media again targeting interesting
people directly so you can always
interact with people on social or you
can write for others attract people from
the web to important pages of your
website by guest posting so you can
always go on to a popular blog post and
write something and you know link it up
or or have it be relevant to the content
you've written so next question how can
you determine how well your content is
doing okay very important again you've
done all the work you've put the content
calendar together you got the content
ready to go it's published you're
promoting it social email guest blogging
but you want to determine how it's doing
well depends on the channel really is
what it comes down to so if it's organic
search you want to be able to see if
it's ranking for the keywords you
optimize that content for if it's social
you want to be able to see if you have
engagement shares comments Etc of course
you can always look at analytics and see
how much traffic that blog post is
getting or that page with the white
paper is getting okay so you can always
look at your analytics and look at the
traffic okay and again you can always
look to see if there are conversions in
the form of an inquiry or lead or sale
so at the end of the day you want to
align the content with the channel and
you want to line the kpi with the
content and channel okay so if it's
social you're not likely going to get
conversions unless you're doing paid ads
if you're posting organically on social
then you're probably gonna get some
engagement so you have to align the
right metric with the right channel what
are the steps involved in the content
marketing process okay so you really
need to decide what goal you want to
achieve with the content marketing
campaign so that goes back to what I was
just saying a minute ago if you have
content you post it on social then
what's the goal what are you trying to
achieve well you're probably going to
get engagement and likes you need to
Define buyer personas to determine the
audience best suited for your content
okay so you're always writing for an
audience and you're going to Market that
content for that audience so you always
got to keep that in mind okay run
content audience audits to determine the
best type of content that can be used in
other words how did it perform what kind
of engagement did you get with the
infographic or did that video really
really perform well or do we want to use
you know a blog post next time around or
an image next time around so continuing
on here you want to choose an
appropriate content management system
okay so how are we managing all this
content okay is it WordPress or is it
another platform okay you could start
brainstorming for ideas for new content
so again that goes back to the content
calendar you leverage your content
counter to always create ideas for new
content okay then you want to settle on
a particular type of content that you
want to create okay so once you come up
and you're managing your content you
know you come up with some ideas then
you obviously want to choose the format
and then of course you want to publish
and manage your content after it's all
said and done so these are the steps
involved again just quickly decide on
the goal the kpi decide on your audience
look at what's worked and not where
worked in the past get your content set
up in the platform okay we'll get the
platform ready to go I should say Okay
generate ideas with that content count
or I ideally go to the content calendar
for the ideas choose that type and then
publish and manage and when I say manage
I mean again going back to analytics or
going back to the kpi that you align
with that content to see if it's
performing or not okay so next question
here how do you target the Right
audience for your content it's a very
good question you're not writing content
for everyone let's be honest here so you
have to collect demographics of your
target audience based on who's coming to
your website based on who subscribed to
your emails based on who's following you
on social media so in other words you
have people interacting with you okay in
different channels and you need to
understand who these people are so or
they fit a certain age range or
generation are they skewed more female
to male education level what's their
Affinity or interest okay do they have a
certain income so you need to really
break down your audience here and you
could do that in analytics you could do
that on social you can do that just by
looking at your email list okay the all
those will paint a picture as to who
your audience is I'm Greg jarbo I'm a
member of the market motor faculty in
this first section we're going to talk
about what content marketing is how it
works and also explore why it works
this seems like a new buzzword to you
it's actually a term that's been around
for quite some time
it's just web search interest in content
marketing has tripled since 2010
according to Google Trends and that's
why a lot of people are now just
starting to get their arms around it so
what is content marketing well according
to Rebecca Lee a friend of mine who
wrote an article in advertising age
content marketing is not just a
glorified way to say social media
marketing it's actually a little broader
concept so content marketing does
include social media and you can use
blogs Facebook Twitter Youtube Vimeo
LinkedIn Google Plus Pinterest
Foursquare Instagram Flickr StumbleUpon
Tumblr SlideShare and quora and you can
put all of those together in a Content
marketing program
and all of this content
can be optimized so it can be found in
search engines as well as in social
media or in the usual places like your
website
one of the ways to sort of conceptualize
this is the classic Venn diagram
Brian Clark of copy blogger has put
together a really interesting white
paper called the business case for agile
content Marketing in which she's created
this particular diagram that shows
search social and content and the
overlap of the three is where he
positions content marketing and that may
help you understand where it fits it's
sort of a little bit of this a little
bit of that but it also shows you both
the potential leverage that you can get
when you begin combining these elements
but also the potential conflicts you may
encounter inside an organization who
says hey wait a second that's my job and
the real challenge to content marketing
is getting people who have been doing
their job independently headed off in
their own unique direction to actually
collaborate and coordinate what they're
doing and leveraging each other's
capabilities to create something that's
a little more powerful
so with that we have reached the end of
day 4 of our digital marketing week on
day five that is tomorrow we are going
to learn about the various digital
marketing tools thank you all for
watching today's live session I hope it
was useful and interesting see you
tomorrow thanks again and keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here